just a quick preface before we get
started John and I got into the weeds We
Got Deep In The Weeds very quickly and
started to discuss how specific words
shape our thinking and consequently our
behavior in the west so we got into
language and quickly that led to a
discussion of how say subjective
objective that distinction did not exist
for a very long time arguably for the
majority of the history of humankind and
so on and so forth but it was very dense
so we took that section it's around 10
minutes long and we moved that to the
very end it is good I think it's super
interesting but because of its density
we moved it to the very end of the
interview so when we wrap if you want to
hear that just stick around for an extra
30 seconds and it'll start back up and
enjoy
[Music]
foreign
hello ladies and germs this is Tim
Ferriss welcome to another episode of
the Tim Ferriss show I'm going to keep
my Preamble short because I would like
to get into the meat and potatoes of
this conversation that I've been looking
forward to my guest today is John
vervaky on Twitter you can find him at
verveiki underscore John he is a
professor of psychology and cognitive
science at the University of Toronto he
currently teaches courses on thinking
and reasoning with an emphasis on
cognitive development intelligence
rationality mindfulness and the
psychology of wisdom viveki is the
director of utoronto's Consciousness and
wisdom studies laboratory and its
cognitive Science Program where he
teaches introduction to cognitive
science and the cognitive science of
Consciousness emphasizing the 4E model
which I'm sure we will get into which
contends that cognition and
Consciousness are embodied embedded
enacted and extended beyond the brain
verviki has taught courses on Buddhism
and cognitive science in the Buddhism
psychology and mental health program for
15 years he is the author and presenter
of the outstanding that's what I'm
adding you YouTube series I highly
recommend Awakening from the meaning
crisis and his brand new series after
Socrates you can find all things John
verviki at johnvervaki.com that is
spelled
v-e-r-v-a-e-k-e
johnvervaky.com John thank you so much
for taking the time today a great
pleasure to be here Tim great pleasure
indeed
could you please elaborate on the four
ways of knowing sure so the idea about a
taxonomy that has to be principled and
so what it is is every every one of
these kinds of knowing has a particular
vehicle a particular result a particular
standard a particular kind of memory so
I I I'm not going through all of these
things to be pedantic I'm going through
to these to show that this is a rigorous
taxonomy that this is like because you
can cut up the world however you want
but in the scientific taxonomy you want
it to be very systematic and rigorous so
the kind of knowing we're most familiar
with and our culture is very fixated on
is propositional knowing this is knowing
that something is the case this is
knowing that cats are mammals knowing
that two plus two equals four and the
standard of realness for that is truth
you're convinced that something is true
and it results in beliefs you get true
beliefs and perhaps they become true
Justified beliefs Etc
and the kind of memory that's associated
with that is called semantic memory so
for example if I ask you do you remember
learning that cats are mammals can you
tell me the day that that really dropped
for you and you go I don't know right
that's semantic memory and the reason
why I'm saying this is all of these
memories are distinct from each other
such that like it's possible to damage
one without the others being
completely damaged
so the next is procedural knowing this
is knowing how this is knowing how to
kiss someone
this is knowing how to kick a ball just
knowing how to swim
right and this doesn't result in beliefs
right this results in skills and skills
aren't true or false but Tim do you know
how to swim
I do right now is swimming true or false
right now
no your misunderstanding skills aren't
true or false they apply or they don't
and they apply powerfully or they don't
and so its standard of realness is
powered
does our know-how Empower us
and then prosaically enough
psychologists call the form of memory
associated with this procedural memory
right yeah now
each one of these I'm going in an order
of dependence the propositional depends
on the procedural and we can get into
that in a minute but I'll just go
through the four first the next is
perspectival knowing this is knowing
what it's like to be so you know what
it's like to be you now in your state of
mind in this situation you know what
you're foregrounding you know what
you're backgrounding you know what is
Salient for you you can sense how the
salience is Shifting around you've got a
sense of how you're fitted to this
situation and this doesn't result in
skills or beliefs it results in
perspectives and you know how to take
perspectives and you know what the
difference between perspectives are
and how valuable it is to have multi
perspectives on a situation
sometimes in order to solve a problem
you shift to a different perspective and
so perspectives aren't true or false
they're not powerful or not their
standard of realness is presence how
present are you in the situation
and in fact
when people do VR work they look for
this how much do people feel like
they're in the game right there's that
that's the perspectival knowing
right that they're really situated in it
that they really belong to it right etc
etc and this has its own kind of memory
called episodic memory so I can ask you
perhaps do you remember what you did on
your last birthday
right and then what you'll do is you'll
remember a particular perspective you
had on a particular situation and your
State of Mind in that situation that's
your episodic memory
now below that and this gets to what we
were talking about earlier is
participatory knowing this is knowing by
being this is the kind of knowing that
results from how you and reality have
been co-shaped to fit together to
generate those affordances so for
example the water bottle and I have both
been shaped by gravity we've both been
shaped by electromagnetism so that we
can there's an affordance there we
they've been both we've both been shaped
right by a biological history which is
Niche construction my ancestors evolved
they made tools that shape the
environment that shaped my ancestors
right and culture has shaped me in this
technology made this and taught me how
to drink out of a water bottle so
there's been all this co-shaping of me
and parts of the environment so we fit
together we're niched together we belong
together affordances are available to me
that's carried in this very weird sense
of memory that you probably don't even
recognize as it's your sense of self
the sense of all of the identities
you've taken up and how they're somehow
historically narratively linked together
to certain narrative histories of
certain situations
so here's the proposal
you have participatory knowing it's
laying out affordances and when that's
missing you know it culture shock or
when you're homesick or when you're
lonely right that participatory knows
John could you just Define affordances
yeah affordance is like the grasp
ability the affordances are real
relations for how you can interact with
the object how that object is available
to you so this affords graspability the
water bottle is graspable that's an
affordance a real relation of fittedness
so me and the water bottle belong
together it makes itself available for
certain interactions and I can shape
myself to interact with it powerfully
and appropriately did that work as it
did work could you perhaps give an
example of an affordance that would come
into play with culture shock so an
affordance would come into play with
culture shock is there are certain
affordances about how you and other
people relate that tell you when
conversation is available to you when
there's an affordance for conversation
and notice that most of this is
unconscious for you know it's even
within your own culture so Tim how how
close should you stand to somebody at a
funeral you know I was just thinking
about the body spacing because I was
just in Japan where it's very very
different I I couldn't give you a
discrete number but it's probably a
feeling associated with it where it goes
from comfortable to uncomfortable right
and you've got that sense of right and
it wasn't working in Japan right so that
that way of connecting to People by
shaping the literal personal space
between you and them was not available
to you that affordance wasn't there does
that yeah yeah that makes sense okay so
the affordances are here and then
The perspectival Knowing makes certain
affordances Salient to me grabbing my
attention arousing my metabolism the
floor is walkable for me right now but
I'm not I don't need to walk right now
so it's not it's not something that I'm
paying attention to right yeah but I
bring it into my situational awareness
with the perspectival knowing that
situational awareness tells me which
skills I should activate which
procedural knowing and then the
procedural knowing puts me into the
causal relationships with the world that
give me the evidence for my beliefs so
that's all the kinds of of knowing and
the point is outside of the
propositional
these other kinds of knowing are built
on the way you are coupled to the
environment dynamically coupled to the
environment and therefore they hearken
back to that participation that contact
we were talking about right and I
suppose it's it's this coupling and
interaction with the environment on a
few different levels in the sense that
you have your sort of skin encapsulated
ego and its interaction with what we
perceive as external elements and then
you have perhaps those who think of Mind
and Body in this Cartesian dualistic way
you have the interaction of the body
with the mind which in some respects is
the entire reason for which the brain
evolved right let me just come back to
semantic memory could you give just
another example of semantic memory
because I don't think I grasped that oh
so like if I ask you are dogs fishes and
what do you say to me I say no that's
semantic memory did anybody ever sit you
down do you remember it do you have an
episodic memory of I remember when I
learned that dogs weren't fishes right
right so it's not bound up with your
particular perspective on a situation or
the state of mind you're in it is this
abstracted fact and that's what
propositions are about they're about
these abstracted facts got it so I've
read somewhere and I can't can't believe
everything I read on the internet so I'd
love for you to fact check this
is there some
interplay between what people experience
as flow States and the activation or use
of multiple forms of knowing or did I
just pull that out of the air no I have
argued for that thesis so I don't know
if that makes it a fact but I would
definitely I would definitely argue on
his behalf I think well I mean I've
published and done work on the Flow
State and I think the flow state is an
example of in our experience a
prioritization of the procedural the
perspectival and the participatory over
the propositional in fact one of the
things people reliably report is that
whole propositional processing drops out
even that narrative Nanny you know the
thing in your head that's like how am I
doing how do I look do people like me
how am I doing maybe I should lose some
weight how am I doing how's my hair
right that all falls away this goes to
what I was saying a few minutes ago
there's this enlivening
enriching of a sense of contact one of
the defining features of the flow status
people feel at one with their
environment they feel dynamically
coupled to it they feel like so that's
participatory they feel that one with it
and the perspectival everything is super
Salient there's an ongoing sense of
discovery of even like almost like
insight and well I've argued it's an
inside Cascade and you're you're getting
even more you're getting super present
and then of course the procedurality is
you just know how to do it you and it
just flow hence the word it just flows
from you and what's really important Tim
is that you know the Flow State
is optimal for people they think they're
at their best well with good reason and
they'll say it's one of the best
experiences they had one of the most
rewarding even more rewarding than
pleasure so much so that asking people
how frequently they get into the flow
state is a good predictor of their sense
of well-being
and so here's the point I want to make
about that
this is a clear example of that
non-propositional connectedness flow is
about
really realizing the transjectivity the
connectedness and how much it
contributes to a sense of agency and
meaning for people yeah I think we're
gonna jump in the the deep end of the
meaning pool shortly let me ask you
first though
given what you just said how highly do
you prioritize getting into flow States
yourself and if the answer is reasonably
high or higher how do you personally
like to get into flow States
so I've said this and I mean this deeply
and I don't mean it as a trivial
commodification taoism is the religion
philosophy of flow right and I've been
practicing
Taoist practices
Tai Chi Chuan janjong each one
she Kung
I got professional training and practice
for 10 years as a shiatsu therapist I've
done it all well not at all that's
pretentious but I've done a lot okay
that's fair right and what those things
do and and this is something I want to
talk to you about at some point they get
me into a flow state but in a particular
way that I think is really important and
this goes to a story I've told I was in
I was in grad school and I I was doing
I've been doing Tai Chi Chuan for about
three or four years I was doing it
really religiously both in the sense of
devotedly and I was doing it like two or
three hours a day and going to the dojo
three or four times a week kind of thing
and some of my fellow students came up
to me and said what's going on with you
what are you doing differently I'm like
oh hi you know you're worried in grad
school that people are going to find you
and so I said I'm doing Tai Chi chuanu
but before I said that I said well why
are you saying that and they said
well because you just might like in
conversations you're much more flowing
and you're much more flexible and you're
much more balanced and you're much more
receptive and it was like oh oh the flow
state that I'm getting into in Tai Chi
is permeating many different domains of
my life and many different levels of my
mind and I thought ah and this is a
question this has become a question to
me what are the contexts that generate
flow that transfers like that powerfully
yeah versus the context where the flow
stays locked into that particular
content that's a great question that is
such a good question yeah and where have
you gone with that
well I've gone with that in several
different directions
and it's very much a work in progress so
I asked for some charity on the part of
listeners this is something I'm very
much working on right now
I'm glad you think it's a great question
because you know even if you get a good
question that then you're a good
scientist then you're doing something
right yeah so one of the things I think
has to do with
whether or not the skill or the skill
set that's being trained in the
particular practice
pick is
relatively indispensable in domains
other than the situation you're in now
ideas about sensory motor movement and
balance and coordination and getting the
cerebellum and the frontal cortex to
talk better to each other that transfers
broadly we've already got a lot of
information like evidence about that
especially the cerebellum cortex Loop
that like even when people are
meditating the cerebellum is firing like
crazy because of the cerebellum cortex
Loop and so if it does that it even
shows up in the metaphors we talk about
balancing equations and Justice being
the balancing of things and scales and
so like you want to find a set of skills
that has that inbuilt potential
and then what I would want to say is the
degree to which
there has been a framework built around
the
situation
a ritual philosophical framework that
helps to afford the translation so
around the Tai Chi Chuan you have taoism
which gives you this way of framing
reality as yin and yang that you can see
instantiated in the Tai Chi but you can
also see it prevalent in the world you
set up the possibility with this
framework for the resonance and so
people who get trapped and I'm not
saying that all video games trap people
but the ones that suffer from video game
addiction
they get the problem that they flow in a
in a world that is not does not have a
framework around it does not tap into
those generally transferable skills and
so they find the external World
depressing because of its absence of
flow potential that drives them into the
game where they flow and then you get
the Vicious Cycle that gets you into the
addiction so I think there's something
about are the kinds of skills that are
being brought into the flow state do
they have this domain general power and
is there a framework around it that
helps people set up these patterns of
resonance between what they're doing in
the practice and how they're seeing the
world and encountering it
yeah it makes a lot of sense to me
if there is some overarching
philosophical framework or religious
framework for that matter within which
you're practicing a given skill there's
a broader context that then extends
whatever you're honing in this specific
situation to other domains and it makes
me think actually of a friend of mine
his name is Josh waitskin he was the
basis for Searching for Bobby Fischer
the book in the movie of course very
very high level chess player but he
talks a lot he no longer plays chess he
does a million other things he was
actually world champion in Tai Chi Push
Hands and what I find most I shouldn't
say most interesting he's a lovely
deeply Soulful guy so it's not that I'm
looking at him as a sort of instrument
of learning Mastery but he is able to
take Concepts from all these different
disciplines and apply them in transfers
to all these other things so for
instance in chess he talks a lot about
practicing the macro in the micro or
learning act or from the micro so he'll
say yeah chess people often novices will
say practice openings but that's kind of
like copying from the teacher's answer
book your your memorizing a lot in terms
of declarative knowledge but you're not
learning principles so he'll say why
don't you start with let's just say
three or four or five pieces on the
board and you're gonna practice
manipulating empty space or pulling into
a vacuum and lo and behold a lot of
those same principles transferred over
to Tai Chi and then he took principles
from Tai Chi and moved them over into
foil boarding
is Tai Chi your go-to break glass in
case of emergency tool in the department
of flow States or do you have other
approaches in the quiver yeah and so and
this comes from the socratic part of my
framework if you want to put it that way
that sounds very pretentious so but
I'm into it I have learned how to get
into the Flow State when lecturing ah
that inevitably affords really good
learning of course not for every student
that would be claimed something that's
impossible no teacher is is a great
teacher to every student right but I
mean I've won teaching Awards etc etc
and that's because of this and very
often students get drawn into it because
there's I I encourage a lot of sort of
Socratic dialogue in the lecture and so
it it very much often becomes a shared
Flow State I become very interested in
shared flow States and what they mean
for how we can unpack
sort of the capacity for insight and
reflection
so that's one of my other go-to areas
let's unpack that a little bit so in
lecturing did you do that naturally from
the outset kind of like Usain Bolt
having just different tendon attachments
and so on you can just run fast so did
that come out of the box
for you or was that a that shared Flow
State in the form of lecturing
a learn skill if so how did you develop
that
so very much a cultivated thing and
deliberately so by Nature I'm I'm almost
pathologically shy
and so
I took I didn't realize it was a lesson
from Aristotle at the time but of you
know you cultivate your character to
compensate for your personality defects
and so I adopted I've read my report
cards from Raid 3 and they were calling
me mini teacher
so taking on the role of the teacher and
I was fortunate to have some really
wonderful teachers that allowed this and
to have classmates that enjoyed it I
mean think of all the conditions how
that could have gone wrong right so very
fortunate
and that was how I started to manage
that situation manage a situation you
mean manage your shyness by yes assuming
the role of teacher yes right the full
sort of persona and the role so Tim if
like this this is close enough to
teaching and I don't mean to put you in
the role of a student I'm not saying
that but it's close enough it's in
proximity for transfer oh I'm a student
yep well anyways it's comfortable but I
mean if you're gonna meet me if you're
gonna meet me like at a social party I
I'm I'm at times indistinguishable from
potted plants right because when I don't
have that role available to me my sort
of natural Constitution comes out so it
was very deliberately cultivated from
very very early on and then as I started
doing Tai Chi Chuan when I started in
grad school hearing about the bleed
that's when I started to teach and
lecture and I looked for it and I looked
for when what broke it and what enhanced
it and I slowly cultivated it more and
more over time yes it was very much a
deliberate long-term cultivation what
enhances because you take just describe
an example out of the Year Harvard
Business School they have these case
study methods and there is ostensibly
supposed to be a fair amount of
interplay between lecture and student
but I would imagine that not all
professors or grad students or whoever
is doing the teaching at the time would
say they're they achieve a flow State
even if they've experienced it in other
places like surfing so what have you
found to be things that enhance that for
yourself and for the students
part of this I'm going to declare a bias
because I have a published theory about
what I think the flow state is I think
it's an Insight Cascade and the
enhancement of implicit learning so it
enhanced we cultivate better Insight
capacities we cultivate better
intuition in an integrated manner
now that ghost so I'm stating the bias
up front but I I think it's a good
theory and I think it's well argued and
well evident so but
what I mean by that is
like more and more I crafted
giving priority to the emergence of
insight or intuition in me as I was
lecturing and not sticking to the script
so strongly but willing to bend so I
used the Jazz analogy I might have the
script of the lecture but I can Riff on
it and I look and I hunger and sensitize
myself for that and then when the
students start to even demonstrate sort
of proto-insight I will I will really
call that out I mean in a positive
manner and draw it out and they get
right and and then and they start
priming each other with insights and
they start priming me and I start
priming them and so it's an easy thing
to State and it's a hard thing to do
because when you're lecturing and when I
do when I teach people how to lecture I
actually try to say I try to get them to
make space for the Jazz because what you
do when you're anxious and one of the
things that really kills it a lot is
Powerpoint right because what you want
is I need to say all of these things and
I need to be a clear and I need to have
this fall everything follow and so you
get really like you you try to constrain
your anxiety with the tightness of this
structure that you built and what that
actually does is that undermines
the possibility of flow and so
it's like Tai Chi Chuan right you you
want to be pung you want to Don't Want
to Be Too Young Too Young you got to
loosen the structure enough so that
insight and intuition flow but not so
much that the lecture becomes incoherent
and you find The Sweet Spot
how did you find Tai Chi or how did Tai
Chi find you oh and there hangs a tail
so I was brought up
in a
fundamentalist Christian
extended family not just the nuclear
family the extended family
and it's only sort of later that I've
come to realize how traumatizing that
was for me and so when I was 15 I read a
couple of books Lord of Light and
Siddhartha Lord of Life by rajas alasni
sidharta by Hermann Hessa fifth business
by Robertson Davies and it really blew
me open it really blew me open and so I
left the Christianity
and I've
you know and like I said I've done some
therapy and other things but
religion your mother religion is like
your mother tongue right it shapes you
in a way that nothing else ever can or
your first love right you know you don't
necessarily stay with that person but it
shapes you in very interesting ways in
in your relationships
and so if you'll allow me a metaphoret
left a taste for the Transcendent in my
mouth but right
and then I got to University and I took
a first year course in philosophy and I
encountered the figure of Socrates and
the project of wisdom and it was like
that's it and of course that is still
with me now that's how profound it hit
me how profoundly
but what happened and then I went into
philosophy what happened in philosophy
academic philosophy now it's changing
now but we're talking about a long time
ago the 80s the topic of wisdom
self-transcendence all these kinds of
things that are rich in the platonic
Corpus like and the neoplatonic it drops
off the it drops off the table and you
talk about skepticism and epistemology
and these are valuable sort of
meta-scientific and metacultural skills
and I value them but that hunger for the
cultivation of wisdom was not being met
and I happened to live in a place where
literally down the road there was the
Tai Chi and meditation center so I
thought you know what I'm going to give
the Eastern philosophies a try and maybe
they will give me what I need for
satisfying this hunger for the
cultivation of wisdom and and I was very
lucky again because first of all
wonderful people and secondly this is
where I got what I would Now call an
Ecology of practices they didn't teach
me one thing they taught me they taught
me a meditative practice the pasta they
taught me a contemplative practice meta
and then they taught me Tai Chi Chuan to
get how to flow between them in a
regular and reliable at this Ecology of
practices and it and that that's how it
happened and that has been with me ever
since wow
that is a very potent and
uncommon Trinity there that's a very
formidable combination of things and I
do want to revisit at some point
meditation as contrasted with
contemplation yes but first I'd like to
ask you how old were you when you
decided to leave Christianity and what
did that what was that experience like
oh
15. yeah and my life became bifurcated
and fragmented in a way that I came to
deeply find
distasteful and so trying to deal with
fragmentation has also become a
pervasive theme not whether it's a
fragmentation within a person or a
fragmentation between the different
disciplines that study the mind that's
why I'm in cognitive scientists trying
to integrate and solve the fragmentation
problem right
yeah it was very challenging for me
because
I I couldn't move out on my own or
anything I'm 15 right right I'm still in
my family and they had they knew that
something was going on and it was kind
of like there was kind of this weird
don't ask don't tell thing it was very
challenging me there were times when I
went to church and you know the minister
would be getting everybody to Bow their
head and raise their hand if they agreed
with this and of course everybody's
looking around surreptitiously and
everybody's raising their hand and I'm
the one person not raising my hand
just very very difficult and then of
course I had a group of friends close
friends at high school they became very
much invested in this project that I was
engaged in of wrestling with meaning and
they really and so they became very
supportive and that was very happy for
me but that was
you know and it caused things and
it caused me to Get Married Too Young
right because marrying was a way of
escaping
that that fundamentalist family and
setting up a new one and
[Music]
um
and I'm on good terms with my ex I'm not
making any criticisms of her I'm just
saying we've we got married I think too
young because we were both escaping that
that's a good reason for forming a
company together for a while like you
know the Fellowship of the Ring or
something we're both going to leave
fundamentalism together we're going to
help but it's not the basis for a
long-term marriage right it's not
of course you don't know this at the
time right the the kind the ways in
which you know I was foolish around this
are significant I was wrestling with a
lot of stuff I was wrestling with a
profound kind of depression used to call
it the black burning in my chest because
of that whole like I said
I can imagine
but also like I said there was trauma
like there's instances like from when I
was still in it as a kid that were
absolutely traumatic to me I came home
one day I lived within walking distance
of the school and there was almost all
there was always somebody in the home
just because of the way it was a small
home we were a poor family there was
kids and you know my mom was mostly a
housewife
and I came home one and there was nobody
there
and I was absolutely convinced to my
bones that the Rapture had occurred all
my family had been taken away I was too
sinful I was left behind and the
Antichrist and his minions were coming
for me
this is like I'm 10.
and then another one I I used to read
the Bible every day and I'm glad I have
by the way biblical literacy is really
important part of Cultural Literacy I
don't begrudge that and the Bible still
is deeply meaningful to me but
I read this passage in the New Testament
where in multiple places they talk about
the unforgivable sin the sin that can
never be forgiven no matter how much you
pray about it and I was terrified and I
thought have I committed like I'm not
like again I think it was like 12. have
I committed the unforgivable sin and I
got like and and is thinking that the
unforgivable sin and all you know and I
was I got oh and my mother could tell I
was getting like I was getting deeply
distressed and she took me to the
minister
who was supposed to help me and he just
gave me empty platitudes that even as a
12 year old I recognized were completely
useless and I realized he doesn't have
an answer to this
he doesn't you know he pretended he had
it he spoke with the confidence of some
but there was no answer forthcoming
and it was just
like that kind of trauma and these are
these are just a couple instances of
many
and again I am not I'm not villainizing
my mom or my dad or my family I love
them
my mom and my dad are both dead I love
my extended family but
this is
when I stepped out of that
that now came to the fore like well
you've got to address this what is the
world such that right you shouldn't have
these fears you shouldn't have these
tears what do you do with the way that
has sort of made you afraid of things
like and so it yeah it took it took work
it took therapy it took meditation
contemplation Tai Chi Schwan
you know a lot of good education
especially in the socratic platonic
tradition
so that's what it was like I wouldn't
recommend it for anybody but the thing I
have to tell you Tim is I meet a lot of
people who are attracted to my work
because of something similar like this
happening to them they have left a
religious home and they they do not find
any religious homes viable yet they
still hunger for that deep connectedness
that meaning that space in which one can
cultivate wisdom
let's segue to this word wisdom because
this might sound strange but the
self-transcendence and the experience of
that
I have some
I suppose experience that lends itself
to
understanding what that means wisdom
though I would love for you to Define
for us
just so so everybody including myself is
on the same page
knowledge is about overcoming ignorance
wisdom is about overcoming foolishness
so you understand wisdom by
understanding foolishness and you
understand wisdom foolishness as not
identical to ignorance these are the
moves you have to make to get the chess
pieces on the board if you want to play
the game we're going to play right and
so
foolishness what is it what what do we
mean by this
and this is an idea that's born in the
axial Revolution the specific notion of
foolishness but this this idea and I
think foreign
publish about it the very processes
that make us intelligent problem solvers
make us so adaptive
are the very same processes that make us
prone to self-deceptive self-destructive
Behavior
you don't get one without the other
so you use your intelligence to solve
problems but you use rationality and
wisdom to deal with the self-deception
that emerges as you're trying to solve
your problems and that's a very
different thing and the thing about
these self-deceptions is they don't come
as sort of isolated little things they
they can constellate into complex
patterns of self-organization you know
the confirmation bias can strengthen
egocentrism which can strengthen the
degree to which you engage in a kind of
narrow framing of situations which can
then feed back into the confirm and you
and we've published on this right you
get these massively complex
so that
the dynamical complex self-organization
of your cognition is hijacked by
self-deceptive processes and they form
these systems that are also complex and
adaptive and hard to intervene on we
call it parasitic processing in the work
that Leo and I published right John
would you mind giving an example because
there are people listening I'm sure a
lot of people listening who Pride
themselves on being good problem solvers
Strong having strong analytical minds
and they're like yeah but I don't see
how that automatically begets
or not automatically but how that would
be good delusion self-deception okay
would you mind giving an example real or
hypothetical well let's use a chess
example okay so here's the problem
facing you in chess you can't actually
check all the possible
alternative Pathways for playing a chess
game the number of alternative Pathways
is greater than the number of atomic
particles in the universe so even the
super fastest chess game can't check all
of the possible alternative sequences of
actions
so that means that's why by the way you
know you get a chess game that beats any
human being or let's do it with go you
get
alphago beats in a human being but then
you can make a machine that beats
alphago because no AI can
algorithmically play and search so what
we have to do is we have to bias what
information we check
this is the Paradox it sounds like a Zen
Cohen right you're intelligent because
of your ability to ignore so much
information in a way that makes obvious
to you the relative information enough
of the time that you're a very good
Problem Solver in very many many domains
so you're playing chess what's a good
heuristic control the center board I've
played with somebody who is controlling
the center board I realized that they
were biasing their attention that way
and so I played a peripheral game and
beat them because they focused on now
should people not focus on the center
board well no it's a very good heuristic
but it's heuristic it's not an algorithm
this is this is a formal thing it's
called the no free lunch theorem there
is no problem solving method that will
universally solve all your problems in
fact the area above the line of average
problem solving where it's improving
your performance is equal to an area
under the line where it degrades your
performance every bias is just a
heuristic misfiring and every heuristic
is just a bias that happens to be
working for us in a lot of contexts
they're interchangeable together and so
even when you're doing analytic stuff
you're confronting this you'll often
realize the way you framed the problem
is actually what's preventing you from
solving the problem you have to have
that aha moment that breaks you out of
it but when you're trapped in it that's
that's that's a form of self-deception
you can't really lie to yourself what
you do is you you bias your attention to
find the wrong thing Salient in a way
that binds you to trying to solve it in
a particular manner this shows up in
interpersonal context I'm sure you had
something like this as an experience
oh oh
I thought she was angry but she's afraid
he's afraid not angry I've been going at
this all wrong
right but that doesn't mean that
sometimes people aren't angry at you and
you shouldn't see them as angry at you
right right and so
even the most analytic thing you're
doing is dependent on
pure logic you're going in to do a logic
class this is from my history and a lot
of people will back me up on this
for a while what you're doing is you're
practicing doing all the Machinery of
the Transformations and the logic trees
and all the derivations you just gotta
practice that and then you realize but
I'm still not getting like really I'm
still only getting B's and lower A's
like what's going on and you and you
keep getting docked not on the logic but
how you translated natural language into
the logic for which there is no logical
procedure right and and so you that
translation process right is needed in
order to get the logical Machinery
running but it is not itself governed in
a purely logical manner it requires this
flexibility this reframing this Insight
this kind of stuff
I wanted to
I wanted to invoke a a word you
mentioned in passing with respect to
flow States in lectures which was
intuition and sure so I wanted to Loop
that in to ask
well
you can pick and choose this is
interviewees choice so one would be how
do you think about intuition versus
logic when it comes to problem solving
or searching for meaning or finding
meaning
alternative question would be what kinds
of problems
is logic poorly suited to solving
sure we'll do that and then I'll tell
you what I think intuition is and what
the powers and Perils of it are great
so the search space right the search
space for very very many problems like
the chess example is combinatorily
explosive it's computationally
intractable and so and this is this is
the seminal work of Newell and Simon and
then Simon and his notion of bounded
rationality and this is the idea that
you can't be comprehensively logical
logic and math are algorithmic they work
in terms of certainty certainty requires
that you search sometimes all or at
least most of the space and if you tried
to do that you would have committed
cognitive suicide that would be the last
thing you do right and that can't be
that can't be a rational way to behave
so bounded rationality is something more
like knowing where when how and to what
degree using all the non-propositional
kinds of knowing to tell you where when
how and what degree you should be
logical you have to cultivate these
virtues for when you use logic so that's
what rationality is and that's a much
harder problem like when should I be
logical and so you have to ask yourself
like if I formulate the problem such
that the search space could be searched
in a relatively exhaustive fashion and
there are algorithms that work that how
many people are present in this
conversation there's an algorithm
counting two one two we're done there
that worked there was nothing with wrong
with doing that right but if you try to
say I want I want to count all the
numbers of possible conversations we
could have and thereby try to figure out
invariant principles through all
conversations it's like well what's a
conversation
and I've been in many ones and you know
there's good ones and there's bad ones
but the good ones like they're not
they're sort of the same they're similar
to each other and the problem with
similarity and this is now the main
argument
is if you try to be logical about
similarity you're doomed what do you
mean by logical about similarity so this
is an argument made by Nelson Goodman
what a great name for a philosopher
Nelson Goodman outstanding 1972 right
and the argument goes like this
so identity is to share all properties
similarity is to share a lot of
properties but not share all properties
kind of the same as Sesame Street used
to say right
so he said pick up any two objects and
you'll find that there's an indefinitely
large number of properties they share
so a plum and a lawnmower they both have
curved surfaces they are both shiny
they're both found in North America both
contain carbon both way more than a
paper clip neither one is a particularly
good weapon how many true things can I
say that apply to both
those indefinitely right indefinitely
large right and that's the case for
anything so if you try to do if you try
to have a logic of similarity it will
not pick out it will it won't help you
sort the world at all so what people
rely on is psychological similarity
which is they say they say to you things
like but none of those property and
here's the key term none of those
properties are the relevant properties
those aren't the important ones and of
course relevance and importance are not
features of a proposition the same
proposition can be relevant one minute
and irrelevant the next this is actually
a formal argument by Jerry foder and
others relevance is not a logical
property if what we mean by logical
properties are syntactic relations
within propositions and implication
relations between them you can't capture
relevance with those syntactic relations
and therefore you can't do a logic of
similarity
maybe this is a good place you can
chastise me if it isn't but to bring in
and Define intuition and
the the powers and perils thereof and to
the extent that you could maybe share
how you harness oh powers and avoid the
perils personally I think that would
make it easy to grasp for folks myself
included excellent excellent oh
wonderful wonderful so
I'm deeply influenced by two things
chick sent mahi's work on Flow and
hogarth's work educating intuition and
he makes a proposal
and I think I I think this is the best
proposal I've heard so if we're doing
inference to the best explanation it's
the best explanation
so we've had a robust research program
from the late 60s starting with Arthur
Reber for what's called implicit
learning
so I'm sorry I need a minute to sort of
describe the experimental Paradigm for
this because sure right so what you do
is you create an artificial grammar for
how you're allowed to string numbers and
letters together like you the grammar
might have the rule you can't have two
odd numbers beside each other you can't
have two vowels beside each other you
can't have more than four consonants in
a row or something like this and you
make these by completely arbitrary
artificial grammar you make these number
letter strings that are like nine or
twelve long so you can't hold them
easily in working memory or anything
like that and so what you do is you give
people you say this is one this is one
not quite this fast but I'm just doing
it right you hold up these strings and
you get people to look at them right and
there's various modifications sometimes
you give feedback and but but that's
just the basic Paradigm now here's what
you do so you're not giving them the
rules in advance is that is that correct
okay so this is purely deductive you're
just giving them examples and saying
this is wow it's not deductive but this
but it's not okay they're purely just
doing this
okay I'll say what I think it is in a
minute okay so and I'll say why it's not
deductible because of an experimental
variation okay so I'm gonna I'm not
gonna I'm not just going to swipe that
aside I'm going to address you the point
okay so you do this and you do this and
you do this and you do this and then
what you do is you say now I'm going to
give you a bunch of strings and and what
you do is some of those strings are new
they haven't appeared yet but they're
generated by the same artificial grammar
right and then some are generated by a
completely alternative or even randomly
generated and then you present them to
people and you say which of these new
strings belongs with the old ones
and people reliably score well above
chance on this yeah well above chance
okay so what people have is the capacity
without explicit awareness or deliberate
effort they can pick up on very complex
patterns now why isn't it deduction
because if you do the following and you
say I'm going to give you the strings
and I want you to figure out the rules
that are generating the strings
the performance degrades and they
actually fall below chance they get
really they get really worse and they
get all tangled up in themselves yes so
what Hogarth proposes is that intuition
is a result of implicit learning you're
picking up on very complex patterns
without explicit awareness or deliberate
effort you know
how close to stand to somebody at a
funeral
but it depends on their status their
closeness to the person their emotional
state how you're feeling it depends on
all of these variables but it depends on
what part of the funeral it is it
depends on
potential religious like there's all
these variables and they're interacting
in complex Dynamic ways and you've
picked that up and you don't know
how you've picked it up you don't know
where and when so you just get the
intuition I should stand this close and
you do it and you're right
now what's the Peril of this so that's
its power you pick up on complex
patterns
and you don't do it deductively and I
gave you the evidence for that right
so what's the Peril with this and this
is hogarth's work and I think it's
powerful
implicit learning doesn't care what
patterns it picks up
right it doesn't distinguish real causal
patterns from correlational patterns
and there's a lot more complex
correlational patterns that aren't real
causal patterns and so we pick up on all
kinds of complex patterns that are not
real and we form intuitions around them
but when we don't like our intuition we
don't call it intuition we call it bias
or Prejudice or racism or sexism or a
whole bunch of other things right and so
hogar says
well
what should we do we can't replace
implicit learning with explicit learning
what can we do explicitly
and he says well what we can do is set
we can explicitly set up the situation
in which we're doing implicit learning
that replicates how science
distinguishes cause from correlation
because that's what science is it's a
practice for distinguishing cause from
correlation so what are those well you
need clear feedback right you need you
need clear information you need clear
and tightly coupled feedback error has
to matter you can falsify the experiment
right and you set that up and if you're
learning in those situations
chances are your implicit learning will
track causal patterns rather than
correlational and then you ask me how do
you do that John well here's John's
answer
chipset mahai says how do you get into
the Flow State what are the
informational constraints the
information has to be clear it has to be
tightly coupled and error has to matter
the exact three conditions that Hogarth
proposes for making sure you're doing
good implicit learning are exactly the
conditions that get people reliably into
the Flow State
and so we've published on that what flow
state is and is an evolutionary marker
that you're getting a lot of insight and
you're getting a lot of insight within
implicit learning that is probably
tracking real causal relationships so
whatever you're doing keep doing it
because chances are you're really
figuring out the environment in a
powerful way
what have you done with this with this
knowledge how is that informed your
behaviors or beliefs as you operate in
the world so I mean I I try to make sure
that we're setting up the explicit
circumstance for flow states that have a
lot of those conditions in them
this goes towards work I'm doing on
shared flow States when people are
getting into dialogically flow shared
flow States deal logos and what are the
contexts we can build around that so
that we can get people more reliably
having Insight Cascades and tracking
real patterns of sense making as opposed
to weird funky correlational things
so I am going to double click on Dia
logos because I've mentioned dialogue
and wanting to get into the etymology of
that just because I'm a nerd about all
that stuff but before we get there could
you could you give a
personal example of how you
have have used this insight and
knowledge based on the studies and the
work of these various people you've
you've mentioned and of course your own
Publications
how is that informed
how you operate in the world
or make decisions
it's giving me a way of challenging a
certain kind of decadent Romanticism in
the culture which says that you should
always trust your intuition
there is no Panacea faculty there is no
Panacea practice
no free lunch theorem and I've become
almost like a preacher or something I
like I've been almost Evangelical about
trying to say stop demonizing any
faculty and stop deifying any faculty
your intuition will lead you as much
wrong as your reason as much wrong as
your emotions as much wrong as whatever
as much wrong as your logic right look
does not tell you how to go from a
weaker logic to a stronger logic I can
do all the possible manipulations within
predicate logic and it won't get me to
motor logic I have to do something
outside of that to actually increase my
logical competence so there's no Panacea
there's no Panacea so that has become
like I have taken that up as a theme and
I do it for myself
this is why I advocate very strongly for
and I was fortunate to be taught an
Ecology of practices there I do not
practice I practice a bunch of practices
that have complementary strengths and
weaknesses that are constantly checking
each other and calling each other out
and constraining each other and pointing
out errors in each other like an ecology
you know how you have the checks and
balances in a biological ecosystem
that is how it had a huge impact on how
I try to cultivate wisdom and virtue and
how I recommend to others how they
should do it I strongly advocate for
practicing an Ecology of practices that
is well designed and what are some of
the design principles for a good Ecology
of practices and then I feed that back
into my own practices and how I try to
teach other people
so I would love to know what questions
you have asked yourself to improve your
ability to spot spurious
or at the very least unhelpful
forms of pattern recognition right so
yeah the intuition we want to avoid
to how you've done that because I've
observed certainly and I'm sure you have
and I'm sure I do it my own way people
who are very methodical about testing
in some scientific empirical fashion
causality and say engineering so they're
they're doing split testing in their job
as an engineer and then as soon as they
jump into the world of say nutrition or
fill in the blank
it all falls apart and
they just seem to found her in spotting
all these sort of yes correlations that
they turn into causation you know really
got a sloppy way and I'm sure I do it as
well so how how have you improved your
ability to spot that
for yourself
I don't want to in any way try to convey
that I I don't fall prey to this how
have I tried to address it is how I'll
frame the question you asked perfect
okay and so first of all that issue that
we were talking about earlier how
pervasively does your practice transfer
to multiple domains and to multiple
levels of your psyche how much does it
engage the non-propositional kinds of
knowing how much is it engaging the
ability to metacognitively shift between
perspectives Etc
for exactly that reason
secondly
it's not the questions you answer it's
practices you do at length for for a
considerable amount of time like I've
practiced first of all I practiced it
very explicitly for like two or three
years and you know in this overlaps
significantly with stoicism right I
practice active open-mindedness like I'm
a cognitive scientist learn about the
biases
and this this is how you get into it
learn about the biases and first spot
them in other people you'll be
astonishingly good at that oh
confirmation bias my side by blah blah
blah blah you're really good at
fundamental attribution error you're
like you're really good at it with other
people but allow yourself to be sort of
overconfident of it and then Practice
Act the second stage which is try to
note
every day
a bias in your own and actively
counteract it oh wait there's a
confirmation bias what would how where
would I look for evidence that could
disconfirm this or who could I talk to
who would challenge me on this
you have to practice it
it's not about getting a rule or a
technique of question it's about
developing a deeply ingrained habit that
helps to work and then and in concert
with this and this is also from stoicism
stoicism is the philosophy religion of
internalizing Socrates and you know
practicing internalizing Socrates
this is antistanis am I getting that
pronunciation right exactly exactly
right yeah what did you learn from
Socrates I learned how to dialogue with
myself but he didn't mean the way we all
talk to ourselves in our head all day
long right and you have to practice that
you have to practice it on your own yeah
I have to practice it with others and
I've been doing that and I've been
developing ways of
honing that like we do these weekend
workshops I do it with guy send Stockton
Christopher Master Pietro we take people
through a meditation practice a
contemplation practice then various
circling practices then various
paraphrasing practices and then we get
them to do sort of a shared lectio
Divina around a philosophical text where
they learn to resonate with each other I
don't know what that means but I like
the sound of it okay and then we take
them into a particular way of engaging
in dialectic and to deal and you have to
practice this and you have to read the
dialogues you have to internalize like
you have to internalize the sage yeah
just like the athlete has to internalize
the coach just like the child has to
internalize the parent and that again is
not a it's not a magic technique it's
something you have to practice like
consistently as a way of life
yeah and degree to which you know I've
internalized Socrates which I've
cultivated habits of active
open-mindedness the degree to which I've
sought out the company of people who
will challenge me in the right ways
because you know people can be also
criticize you in the wrong ways so it it
takes discernment
that's how I'm trying to address what
you've asked me all right so I want to
attempt to create a bridge between what
you just said
and
do so for the listeners and to do so by
giving some examples of the forms of
exercises that you mentioned in passing
and this is also a way of delivering on
the promise I made earlier to people
that we would get into meditation versus
contemplation so could you could you
give an example
and I apologize if this is sort of a
asking for a heavy lift but yeah I think
it'd be helpful for me and hopefully
listeners so so you mentioned meditation
I'm sure I'm going to miss something
contemplation circling I don't know what
that means yeah paraphrasing I believe
yeah lectio Divina am I getting that
right well actually the practice is a
variation on it called philosophical
Fellowship okay perfect so could you
walk us through these and just give an
example of an exercise
what that might look like
in each of those
sure
so I mean first of all the distinction
between meditation and contemplation you
know I've been talking throughout about
how you frame situations what you make
Salient What You background and what you
ignore so think about that like the lens
and the frame of my glasses right and
and I'm not aware of my lenses or my
frame because I'm aware through them
Beyond them and by means of them so
they're transparent to me now sometimes
and what I'm doing right now everyone
I'm taking my glasses off because there
might be something on my lenses and now
they're not transparent to me I'm not
looking through them I'm looking at them
that's what meditation is it's about
trying to become aware step back and
look at your mental framing so what you
do is for example
you try to get people to look at
something they're normally looking
through like their Sensations
so for example I teach people how to
center but like they're following their
breath
and you want to follow the whole of your
breath going in and you want to feel the
sensations of the breath and of the
expansion of your abdomen and the
sensations of your abdomen Contracting
in the breath coming out
and what happens is right you're paying
attention to the sensations and very
quickly your mind goes to no I wanna I
wanna look through things I want to look
at the world now I should be doing my
laundry or when is the meditation going
to be done or I wonder if Susan still
likes me and then what you do is you
step back and look at that distraction
you don't look at what you're thinking
about you label the process thinking
imagining hoping wondering and then you
return your attention to your breath and
so what you're doing is you're learning
to step back and look at your framing
now think about this even in the analogy
if I just if I just take my glasses off
and look at them and maybe I wipe them
and I wipe them and I wipe them and I
wipe them how do I know if I've actually
cleaned them what do I need to do gotta
put them back on you gotta put them back
on and see if you now see more clearly
and deeply than you used to before that
is contemplation it comes from the Latin
word contemplative which is a
translation of the Greek word theory
which is where we get our word theory
from which means to look deeply into
reality
so the pastner is this act of I'm
stepping back and looking at but meta is
a contemplative I'm trying to look I'm
trying to see if how can I see you
better
than I used to so in meta I'm trying to
open up and see if I can see you better
or I may contemplate the impermanence of
existence I'm trying to see I'm trying
to I'm not just thinking or saying I'm
trying to realize the impermanence of
things that's a contemplative act it's a
direction outward and for folks who
aren't familiar with meta is it fair to
describe that as loving kindness
meditation well it depends what you mean
and this is where the controversy
so if you think of loving kindness as a
particular good emotional state you're
going to get into I would argue you're
confusing a method with a goal Okay so
positive emotions this is Frederickson
and other work they open you up they
make they make you curious they they
afford wondering they allow you to
questions things they they put you into
an explore mode but it's the exploration
that's important what I'm actually
trying to do in meta is
I'm trying to open myself up so that
this overlaps with stoicism too right so
so the stoics have this idea that
whenever we're going into situations
we're automatically assuming identities
and assigning identities I'm the
professor you're the student or I'm the
the scientist and you're the famous
podcaster or whatever right right and
we're and we're doing that and you know
I'm this and this is a tool a water
bottle but of course it's not it's not
that in and of itself right and so what
that co-identification process is
happening
mostly mindlessly automatically and
reactively and the stoics were trying to
get us aware of this right and in in
meta what you're trying to do is get
aware of
what identity am I assigning to you
what identity am I assuming and how is
how is that locking down the situation
and how can I open it up in an
exploratory way so that more of your
suchness what you are beyond my assigned
categories and identities can start to
shape how I see you and who I am and can
be starts to be shaped by resonating
with that and now I'm trying to see more
deeply into you the Buddha warns against
positive emotions just as much as he
warns against negative emotions like the
idea I don't like the North American
interpretation of meta as I want to
really feel really good about people
I think that confuses it with Christian
Notions of forgiveness
and other things what it is is
can I come to a place where your
identity and my identity can be born
afresh right here and right now and what
that can do for transforming both you
and I as a real possibility
um
okay thank you for that clarification
and it makes sense that I mean there
would be some conflating with what you
mentioned with the especially with the
labeling of loving kindness
by a lot of people in the United States
just given the given the history can I
Riff on that just one second because
that goes towards a fundamental
understanding of misunderstanding of
love is not a feeling okay first of all
right but love is not even an emotion
when I love somebody that can make me
angry jealous sad happy joyous love is
an existential binding it's an
existential stance it's a commitment to
this co-identification process and it
being something by which each of us can
bring out the good and and cultivate
deeper personhood for each each other
love isn't an emotion it isn't a feeling
so thinking that loving kindness is
cultivating a particular emotion is not
only mistaking the Buddhist idea it's
just misunderstanding What Love Is Love
isn't an emotion it isn't a feeling it's
an existential stance of commitment to
binding your identity to the identity of
something or someone else
so meditation contemplation
I'm not sure which came next
paraphrasing circling circling what
would be an example of circling
so that's where you've got it you gotta
talk to guy senstock at some point I
mean circling is this practice
and the best way I could describe it and
it takes there's a lot of exercises and
skills you have to build to do the
practice well so I don't want people to
misunderstand I'm not like I'm just
talking for for Simplicity right I'm not
giving you the full secret sauce or
something like that
the best way to describe it is how can
you and I get into
you know what stereoscopic vision is you
know the left and right visual fields
and they they integrate so you get depth
so I want stereoscopic mindfulness and
what does that mean I want mindfulness
into me and mindfulness into you
and in a way that's affording you to get
mindfulness into you and mindfulness
into me and then we resonate on that
it's a way of being like I noticed that
you leaned forward and did this what's
happening in you right now is you're
doing that and then you tell me and then
you tell me what you're noticing in me
and you get this kind of you know
accelerating mutually disclosing
mindfulness enhancement and it's very
very powerful practice
and then what you can do is you can you
can use that training to really
strengthening the listening skill so you
do you you practice circling with people
they start to pick up on this kind of
what is it's interesting Tim what people
report is they discover a kind of
intimacy they didn't know about it's not
sexual intimacy it's not friendship
intimacy but it's this other kind of
intimacy they say paradoxical things
like this regularly they say this new
kind of intimacy but I've always been
looking for it like they didn't know it
but they've always been looking for it
is this really sounds like a psychedelic
experience
I don't think that's actually Off the
Mark I've got a hypothesis you're doing
circling with multiple people and you're
having to do this multiple switching up
perspectives and inhabiting an
indwelling of other people and letting
them indwell you and it's getting areas
of the brain to talk to each other that
normally don't talk to each other very
very similar to a psychedelic experience
I'm not going to say when I have done
Silo Simon but there was
phenomenological overlap from my
experience of that and my experience in
deep flow yeah and then you move people
to paraphrasing so they get the circling
ability they're into that and then what
you do is I'll say something
and you stopped me after this and you
have to paraphrase back to me with using
as few as my words as possible until I
agree that that's an interesting
constraint yeah you can't just pair it
back from memory right you have to
understand and convey and and the person
gives you feedback no you didn't get it
yes you did and you practiced doing that
right what is the intent the objective
the intent is to realize that one half
of communication is listening
shocker
which is easy to say but hard so you
slow down and you make space and you let
it impact you more deeply yeah you
really have to slow down to operate
within that constraint not using the
same language exactly exactly and then
you move into philosophical Fellowship
it it's it's a thing I've derived from
Randall haves philosophical
contemplative
companionship or I forget what he calls
it he and I have emailed it's so what
I'm doing is not the same but it was
inspired by
so it goes something like this
you pick a philosophical text and you
prime people into this we're not going
to be reading this text in order to get
information from it we're going to be
reading this text in order to be
transformed by it we're going to use
this text as a way of trying to presence
a sage it's almost like a secular Seance
right you're going to put you're going
to presence a stage
so that remember we talked about earlier
internalizing the sage that you really
can't do that unless you know the
presence of the perspectival knowing of
the sage is available to you so what
happens is first of all you read the
text very slowly
and then the speaker will pick out a
phrase that he or she thinks conveys
it and then everybody chance it like in
sequence and they chant it and they're
trying to convey as much and also
resonate with what they're sensing other
people are conveying so it's like jazz
and you do this and then you move into
simple speech everybody is allowed to
say no more than three sentences about
what is being provoked invoked and
evoked in their interaction with the
text and they have to try it and the
task is I want you to convey as much as
you possibly can in as few words as
possible
and so everybody does this but you can't
just do it atomically you have to pick
up on what other people have said when
you do your right simple speech and you
do that for several rounds and people
and what happens is people are also
asked try to sense how all of these
different perspectives converge back to
Spinoza or Plato or buber or whoever it
is and then you're doing that and then
you move into extended speech
everybody's now allowed to give three or
four sentences a bit more and open it up
and they can even relate it to some
experience that they've had in their
life
and you can see it's and then you move
into Free Speech where people just talk
about it and what happens is people get
a sense of
the text coming alive and Spinoza being
present or boob or being present
obviously not literally but in this
sense of there's something about the
intersection in the we space that gives
them a sense of what what was the mind
that generated or is the origin of all
of this and you're sort of and you
resonate with it and you pick it up and
it gives you an opportunity to
internalize the sage
I would love to try that have any of
those experiences been so memorable that
to this day you remember a specific
phrase from a text that
helped to catalyze
just an extraordinary
experience are there any that that
you've seen really light things on fire
in an interesting way
I think one in Spinoza was God is
related to the world the way the mind is
related to the body
oh can you say that one more time I'll
have to marinate with that one God is
related to the world in the same way the
mind is related to the body
I forget where that's from I think it
might have been from the inundation of
the intellect I'm not sure I would
definitely need more time to ramp up my
RPMs to begin to chew on that but what
does that mean to you
he's trying to challenge Descartes
within a Cartesian framework which is
part of the Brilliance of Spinoza that's
why his book is called the ethics but he
presents it as
Euclid's elements he prevents it as this
completely logical
argument with theorems and proofs and
the it's like God is to the world as the
mind is to the body yeah because what
he's trying to say there
and by the way he's not the only person
say I can find similar things in like
Maximus the Confessor from the Orthodox
Christian tradition
but what he's trying to say is like you
have to understand that the order of
causes that's your body and the Order of
intelligibility are actually they have
to fundamentally well be in contact they
have to conform to each other or we're
lost no knowledge is possible for us
right and so the mind which is the
tracking of intelligibility and the body
which is the laying out of causal
patterns have to interpenetrate
and like map onto each other in this
profound way kind of like the way
the software and the hardware mesh
together within a computer and then that
is how odd is related to the universe
God is related to the cosmos
that God isn't some other thing God is
the intelligibility that's non-logically
identical with the causal patterns of
things
could you restate that for a knuckle
dragger like me remember I'm from Long
Island originally
how do you relate to God now I'd be so
curious to know if you use that word at
all if it is a word that you use what
would be a simple way of describing to a
you know five-year-old
yes I am comparing myself to a
five-year-old
what that means to you I appreciate the
framing and excuse me if I get sometimes
convoluted I'm trying not to do that I'm
really enjoying this conversation I want
to keep the flow of it going yeah me me
too I'm enjoying it too so I'm a
non-theist
and this is the idea that there are a
shared set of presuppositions of modern
theism ancient theism is a very
different form of theism but modern
theism and modern atheism shared
presuppositions and they go like this
something like
God is the Supreme Being the ultimate
being the super thing
and the best way to relate to God Is by
having beliefs about him her it
and that sacredness is to have true
beliefs about this super being and to
govern your life accordingly and the
theist and the atheist both agree to
that definition and the theist says yes
and the atheist says no and the
non-theist says I reject all of those
presuppositions I don't think of
Ultimate Reality as a thing
I don't think of it as a being I think
of it as the ground of being and being
is a no thingness it is not a thing it
is that in which all things
come to be being isn't a being which is
like and this is
this isn't something you can just guess
you're very Taoist The Tao that can be
spoken of is not the Dao right and the
naming is the Myriad way right and and
The Emptiness of the cup is what makes
the cup function right all of these
non-thangness metaphors it's like water
right right they're all trying to get
you to understand that being the really
real isn't a thing it's a no thickness
which is not the same thing as
nothingness
and that
we can enter into a profound
relationship with that no thickness let
me give you an analogy I love my partner
she's an amazing woman and I'm fortunate
to be with her
I do not think I will ever completely
grasp or understand her because there is
something about her that always is
transcending herself and transcending my
understanding of her there is something
in that sense properly mysterious about
her any frame I put around her
she shines into it but she also
withdraws from it in further into the
mystery that she is and that's why I'm
continually to I continue to fall in
love with her and so that mystery of no
thickness is something into which we can
fall deeply in love
the no thingness in me for example
what's the no thing this in you
every time you step back remember the
glasses and look at yourself there I am
that James makes this move other people
William James other people
right that's the observed self but
that's never the observing self
yep the observing self can never be
brought into view that is not anything
that can be seen by you it is that which
makes any seeable thing seeable to you
right there's no thing this in you
and that nothingness in you can come
into deep resonance with the no
thingness of Ultimate Reality such that
you fall in love with it and this is not
about belief this is about deeply
coupling so that it discloses itself
more and more to you as you are drawn
Beyond yourself more and more like the
way you fall in love with another person
and so you can learn to fall in love
with
the depths of reality and it's like
it is a source of intelligibility that
is never exhausted but it is not itself
directly intelligible because if it is
there would have to be a principle
behind it that made it intelligible it
is the principle of intelligibility so
it is not itself intelligible and that
was is precisely what makes it sacred
I reciprocally love it open myself up to
it it is an inexhaustible fount of new
intelligibility new insight new
connectedness new meaning I think that's
a proper understanding of sacred that
isn't primarily about believing
propositions
so I'm a non-theist and I understand God
to be a way of pointing to that
great very very helpful and as you're
talking about the sacred and that maybe
I'm already losing track of the
definition that you just provided but
I'm wondering if
Tai Chi or Libby put it in in some
context If you experience the sacred if
one of the indicators or precursors of
experiencing the sacred is a sense of
timelessness and if that's something
that you seek or experience in your sort
of ecology of practices including Tai
Chi I'm wondering if that factors in
somehow yes it does and many Traditions
sort of do this like timelessness and
that's the proper meaning of Eternity
eternity doesn't mean everlastingness it
means not bound by time in space like
two plus two equals four right or n
equals mc squared for that matter where
is it where like where is it when is it
those questions don't make any sense
right
now that is a way of bringing you into
because eternity is timeless spaceless
it's no thingness like it doesn't have a
space it's not it doesn't have a spatial
temporal location like a physical thing
like for example where is E equals m c
squared
right it's everywhere and nowhere it
doesn't make any sense
so the realization of Eternity
timelessness you aptly described it not
unending time right that is a way of
opening up to how being is distinct from
beings but you have to make the move
this is Plato you have to ascend out of
the cave but you also have to return
back down into the cave which is you
also have to see that being also is and
it is within and includes the beings
like
the sacred is within everything but not
enclosed by it it is beyond everything
but not excluded
if that makes any sense that's so the
timelessness is a move but then it's
dialogical you make the you come out and
then you come back and you see you see
the world in a grain of sand in heaven
in a wild flower you hold Infinity in
the palm of your hand and spend eternity
in an hour
Blake that's how you get to the
cultivation of wisdom
part of the reason I asked is that for
instance I have friends who surf and yes
they describe their experiences of flow
As Time stopping or not existing and
they will also say and they'll also say
you know the ocean is my church I just
came back from a trip where a mountain
guide said you know the mountains are my
church and so that to me brings up the
question of
whether one
worthwhile Pursuit would be trying to
find activities that provoke this sense
of timelessness to fill the void that
was left when religion
vacated the premises for so many people
in in the modern world I don't know if
if you have any any thoughts on that I
have a lot of thoughts on that that's a
big part of what went into an Awakening
for the meaning crisis I mean I think
there's a Continuum from insight to flow
to Mystical experiences to higher States
Of Consciousness and I think you you
want to you want to expand your
cognitive flexibility your cognitive
competence so that you can experience
the whole continuum
and you want to situate it within an
Ecology of practices that is guarding
you against self-deceptive [__] and
all that kind of thing but those you
know flow and awe and profound senses of
at one minute or a sense of non-duality
I use the term for this sense of
connectedness religio which is one of
the purported possible etymological
roots of the word religion that's why
they and I think what people are saying
is I got this profound sense of
connected to to myself and to the depths
of reality when I'm in the mountains or
when I'm the the ocean right and you
know Aquinas called God an ocean of
being right and I'm connected to this
right and and what this does is it gives
me a sense of
being deeply coupled
to
but is deeply real within and without
and I think there are ecologies of
practices that can do this for people
outside of an explicit religious
framework now I would say that
dismissing the religious Traditions as
if there's nothing we need to learn from
them I think that's also a mistake I
agreed I think we should respectfully
dialogue with them and learn as much as
we can and I've said this before if
people take from my work a way of how
they can return to a religious home
I think they get more out of Islam they
get more to Buddhism they get more of
Christianity great I am not I'm not in
dispute with that but I also want to
help afford
an Ecology of practices for the nuns the
n-o-n-e-s's the people who just who say
they have no official religious
affiliation for all kinds of reasons
is there a way for them to find I'll use
your the metaphor your friends gave is
there a way for them to find a church or
Temple or mosque which they mean a set
of practices that gives them that
profound religio
yes there is and this is important we
need the solution to the meaning crisis
in nihilism is not to brow people with
argument or legislation it's to enable
them to fall in love with the depths of
reality within and without and between
again that is what we need
let me ask you this is gonna maybe seem
like a non-sequitur but I I imagine you
have some thoughts
first as a bit of background
I know Many religious people and all
over the world and the connective tissue
the pattern that I think I have observed
in those who seem to be and this is this
is a bit of us
content at peace yes is
among other things a strong sense of
community yes and this specific
Community I'd like to ask you about
are sufis ah because one of my most
fascinating
acquaintances well I don't know if he
would call himself Sufi but he certainly
studies Sufism and is deeply immersed he
lives in the Middle East
what are your thoughts observations if
any
a couple of things from my biography
when I went to shiatsu boot camp I
learned jatsu as I said and one of the
one of the people teaching was was a
Sufi Master a huge impact on me
and my partner her her family her father
his father was within the Sufi tradition
because they're Persian and so Sufism
right very very profound
and a lot of the Poetry that they treat
and I mean this as a compliment not as a
insult they treat the Poetry religiously
and other people right and a lot of it
is maybe not directly Sufi but deeply
influenced by Sufism deeply influenced
right and Corban who has influenced me
profoundly around the imaginal also
deeply influenced by sufis what was that
name
c-o-r-r-b-i-n he's the guy that sort of
coined
the difference between the imaginary and
the imaginal
and things like that and then I do a
practice one of my practices is what I
call responsive poesis poesis is the
Greek word for poetry but it also means
making the way we make new sense that we
didn't have before and what I'll do is
I'll read in alexio Divina fashion this
this not reading for information but
reading for transformation I'll read a
Sufi poem and then I'll try and write a
poem in response it's not it's not
trying to parody it or parrot it or
repeat it I'm I'm responding to it it's
responsive poesis well it's like the
paraphrasing it's very interesting yeah
it's very very but not just paraphrasing
but even more like like I've really
heard you and now this is what I this is
how I can respond to what you've said so
the Sufism is really important to me in
that sense
now you have to be really careful you
don't want to engage in inappropriate
cultural appropriation you don't want to
commodify things
you want to receive things as they're
given and in respect
but for me Sufism is important because
it represents
it represents well part of a thesis I've
been arguing for which is neoplatonism
has this tremendous capacity to enter
into reciprocal reconstruction with
other powerful World Views cultural
Frameworks it did that with Christianity
it did that with Judaism Kabbalah it
does it with Islam in Sufism
Sufism is directly they even they will
even talk about platinus
neoplatonism is also capable of entering
into reciprocal reconstruction
with science it did it at the late
Renaissance and helped give birth to
science by the way Kepler and Galileo
are deeply influenced by neoplatonism
and it did it at the beginning of the
20th century a lot of the people around
the einsteinian revolution are deeply
influenced by neoplatonism and things
that are somewhat similar like vedanta
and other things like that
so it's really powerful
I should have asked this earlier but I
was planning on coming back to it so
neoplatonism I understand I think I
understand what Neo means and certainly
Plato but neoplatonism what is that
for those of us including myself who
honestly could not give a definition
so it's the grand unified field theory
of ancient philosophy as a way of life
not academic philosophy but philosophy
as a way of life for the cultivation of
wisdom and meaning and virtue
individually and collectively what it
does is it integrates
Socratic platonic spirituality
with Aristotelian ideas about
knowledge as Conformity contact with
stoic principles of how to properly
cultivate
virtue
and metacognitive abilities and it
integrated them all together and not
just as some Lego blocks being put
together but organically so they all
came to I would argue a greater fruition
within that integration and so it became
this like Grand Unified
powerful living framework so much so
that when it encounters major world
religions they typically can't ignore it
or dispense with it they typically enter
into profound integration with it like
in Christianity like in Judaism like in
Sufism like in science and it looks like
if Thomas plant is right along the Silk
Road possibly with vedanta possibly with
Buddhism
okay so we are going to continue this
thread but I wanted to pause to return
to the personal if you wouldn't mind I
don't mind okay and this you'll have to
Pardon maybe the
with this question is couched but
I just read Lonesome Dove which is 950
or 908 pages and then now I'm watching
the three-part television series with
Robert Duvall and so on which is very
good but I'm noticing things have to get
omitted many many many many things have
to get omitted and so they're trying to
hit the most seminal moments from this
Pulitzer prize-winning novel about the
the American West
if one were to make a film about your
search for meaning or your creation of
meaning over your life what would those
seminal moments
be but with some of those Milestones be
leaving Christianity
encountering Socrates
finding the the Tai Chi Med of a pasta
Ecology of practices
reading Pierre Hado and rediscovering
ancient philosophy not as discourse but
as a way
of life
discovering four e cognitive science
that gave me a way of talking about
wisdom and self-transcendence
and flow and embodiment that was
consonant with what I was learning from
these two wisdom Traditions the socratic
neoplatonic tradition
and the sort of protozan the
Buddhist Taoist
and
then
teaching a course at U of T called
Buddhism and cognitive science
a student then coming to me after taking
the course and saying you should put
this on a you as a YouTube series that
became Awakening for the meeting crisis
because of that meeting people who
became very interested in these ideas
about ecologies of practices we didn't
do the final one by the way we didn't do
dialectic and ideologos yes we should do
that well maybe another time but anyways
yeah and meeting people like guy and
meeting Christopher Master Pietro people
say this and I I again asking for
charity from the audience right because
this could sound ridiculously
pretentious but people often say if I'm
Socrates and that's why I aspire to be
at least right Chris is Plato
and I totally agree with that the
natural lyricism the eloquence the gift
of reflection the authenticity the death
meeting him getting to work with him
meeting of course my current partner
that that would be I guess the arc right
now
could you say more about if I'm getting
the pronunciation right Pierre Hado is
that right yes
when I was asked I think it was Jules
Evans on Rebel wisdom the book that
changed my life I picked what is ancient
Philosophy by Pierre Hado
that book and philosophy as a way of
life
and this is where hudeau brings out that
philosophy is not primarily about the
propositional it's not primarily about
declarative discourse
philosophy is a way of life in which
you're training skills
states of Mind perspectives traits of
characters and that those are all the
components of virtue so that you're that
that's what philosophy as a way of life
is about it's about what Hado called
spiritual exercises by which people
entered into this process of profound
aspirational transformation for the
cultivation of virtue and the deepening
of the love of wisdom and this just blew
me away because it represented what I
had actually saw in ancient philosophy
but what had not been provided to me by
academic philosophy and so that just
opened up so much for me
all right so books
you are kind of you think fairly fair to
say a connoisseur of books you're an
Avid Reader you also have an extensive
reading list on your website you have
the Awakening from the meaning Crisis
book list
if you were only allowed to choose two
books that you could personally reread
from that it doesn't have to be exactly
two it could be one could be three it
doesn't really matter but you were
disallowed from ever re-reading
other books in the list you only got to
choose two or three
which one two or three would you choose
potentially
Plato's dialogues and platinuses Aeneid
hmm what are the reasons for those two
those books are sacred to me
remember I talked about synchronous as a
an inexhaustible fount of
intelligibility this reciprocal opening
with the world I read Plato it
transforms me I go out and see things in
the world I hadn't seen I live that way
and then that feeds back into me and
transforms me and then I read the text
as a transformed person and I see things
I hadn't seen before that opens me up I
now go out into and that just keeps
happening and it's been happening since
I first read the republic since I first
read this Symposium I read platinus is a
need on the nature of beauty or on the
nature of one and contemplation on
dialect any of these greater needs and
and what's what's astonishing about
platinus
and it's neoplatonism so you need to be
educated in platonism stoicism
aristotelianism so I don't recommend
people just pick up platinus
read some good secondary sources on it
first
but
imagine you could read a text
that was simultaneously a profound
philosophical argument and a spiritual
exercise that was transforming you the
way meditation and contemplation to and
they were woven together with
Irreplaceable Artistry that's platinus
that should be the the book blurb on the
back of the cover
if you could only choose two poets to ah
nourish your soul for lack of a better
way to phrase it
that could be two to three again we
don't need to be exact about it but who
would make the short list for you rilka
is first and foremost for me hmm
I won't get it perfectly but the poem
that goes something like ah not to be
cut off even by the slightest partition
from the law of the Stars what is it
what is it if not intensified Sky hurled
through with birds and filled with the
Winds of homecoming
and it's like yeah that's what the
experience of the Sacred is like or you
read the archaic bust of Apollo and he
does all this thing and you're just
you're drawn into this this statue and
it's coming alive and then he suddenly
breaks it and says You must change your
life that's the Deep response to Beauty
that's the most appropriate response to
Beauty you must change your life
right so relka hands down the second the
second one is a bit of a toss-up for me
probably Blake
Blake has a profound I quoted Blake a
few minutes ago
but you know there's you know Gerard
Manley Hopkins and Yates also really
really important for me
do you think it's important to find
poetry that resonates for yourself
predominantly in your native language
no look it doesn't which is yeah because
Rook is in German yeah I did enough
German way back when in order to get my
PhD a long time ago in a galaxy far far
away
but
yeah I can't read German now certainly
not the way you need to be able to read
it to to pick up on poetry but relka
still just
ryoka still moves me profoundly even in
translation
so yeah all right fantastic thank you
you know funny enough I was I was
listening to Coltrane Jazz before this
conversation
which maybe was a good warm-up for the
conversation and I have a new
translation of roomy poetry oh yes and
it is by I'm not going to pronounce this
correctly but Hale Lisa gafori and as a
Persian
Persian American I mean her knowledge of
the language so enriches
how she is able to convey
passages that could be real stumbling
blocks for anyone who is basing their
translation off of another translation
or who is a non-native yes speaker it's
very hard to translate period but it's
even harder to translate poetry it's
like do you choose the Cadence do you
choose to try to match the alliteration
or what what the equivalent of
alliteration would be it's such a
formidable task I was very impressed by
the book yeah I would be remiss if I
didn't ask you if you're open to a few
more questions I'm finally I'm enjoying
this let's keep going all right
wonderful 4E I think this is important
for us to discuss what are the four e's
so I think we should have sixes but I'll
tell you what the standard four ease are
and then the bonus too I'm into it so
this is the idea that cognition is
inherently
embodied firstly
embedded coupled to the environment
secondly
right enacted right cognition is
something that you are doing it's not
something you have right it's between
you and the world not within you right
and then extended most of our cognition
is not done inside of us it's done
through the world
and this this includes other people
so for example you and I are having a
conversation right now we're solving a
problem and this is depending on people
building computers setting up
the internet setting up
Zoom or Riverside neither one of us
invented the English language
Etc and so I and all of these things and
even literacy like literacy is not
natural but we internalize it but it
allows us to link our cognition in
profound ways and so most of our problem
solving is done in an extended way
I guess the classic book by this is
cognition of the Wild by Ed Hutchins
where he talks about the fact that
nobody no person navigates a ship
there's a whole bunch of different
people doing different roles and a whole
bunch of equipment and they form a
dynamical system that is actually
responsible for navigating the ship
myself and one of my my dear friends and
great co-authors Dan chappie we've
published three papers on NASA
scientists moving The Rovers around on
Mars right and
how do how do they form this distributed
cognition especially with that huge time
Gap right the time delay and how do they
make it work and how does that
distributed cognition work and because
they get very powerful sense of an
emergent kind of we agency that's above
and beyond just adding the parts so
that's that's the extended so
embodied embodied means you don't have a
body you are a body and your mind and
your body are not separate things
they're different aspects of what you
are
and and people may say what do you mean
by that what do I mean by that well
remember I said earlier
like you have this problem you're facing
which is
what do I pay attention to
right why do I focus my attention to
what do I ignore and this is not cold
calculation it's also your affect it
means what do you care about and what do
you not care about read Montague the
neuroscientist put it really well he
said the difference between us and
computers is we care about information
and they don't
right and and that's our great strength
and our great weakness now the thing is
why do you care about information
you care about information because and
this is the work of Evan Thompson a
colleague of mine well he was at UFT
still friend right it is is you you are
a self-making thing that's what a living
thing is you care about information
because you are Moment by moment taking
care of yourself not that yourself is
over here and you're taking care of it
you are a self-organizing self-taking
care of thing and because of that you
have to care about this information
rather than that information and and
organisms with other bodies presumably
have different salience landscapes
wickenstein famously well said even if a
lion could speak we would not understand
them
because even if they were using English
correctly what they found relevant and
Salient would be bizarre to us because
they have different bodies that are
embedded in different environments and
that is not happenstance that it's
constitutive of you being a cognitive
agent if you were not embodied you do
not have any reason for caring about
this information rather than that
information and then you have faced the
fact that the world is combinatorily
explosive in the amount of information
available to you
yeah this is very ineptly what I was
trying to convey very early in the
conversation
predominantly and I encourage people to
find this it's not going to be
immediately coming to the tip of my
tongue but Steve durbinson who's
very technical investor I think he did
electrical engineering and mechanical
engineering degree in three years at
Stanford or something like that I'm
probably getting some of the specifics
wrong but he's been on the podcast
before and he had this very long
Facebook post discussing why it would be
difficult if not impossible to
experience anything as a human if we
were just brains in a jar yes brain of
that problem yes yeah Brandon of that
problem and I found it very compelling
and sort of embarrassing that it wasn't
self-evident to me right off the bat
it's like without
these appendages and this this this
multifaceted organism to interface with
an environment
it's what we experience as Consciousness
just doesn't seem at least offhand to be
possible
which makes it very precious that we
have this experience yeah
being embodied is is really wonderful
actually
yeah so what are the two e's
that lead to six
emotional the idea that
are knowing and are emoting are
separable things
I think is one of the great mistakes
that came out of the Enlightenment
Romanticism conflict
being rational ratio proper
proportioning it's about putting things
into perspective perspectival knowing
and caring about them in the right way
and knowing within that when and where
and how to be logical etc etc we've
already talked about that hmm
and
I mean a good a good place to point
people about this is dimasio's Descartes
error right you have people who have a
certain kind of brain damage
and they have the frontal cortex is
working such that you could give them a
standard IQ test and they could do all
the computations quite well in it but
you could drive them insane by saying
before you take the test I want you to
choose should write it in red ink or
black ink or blue ink
and then they go crazy because they have
no motivation they have no affect they
have no reason to care about this rather
than that and so they right
emotion and cognition are interweaving
and inter-affording
emotions are not irrational like I said
there is no one faculty that is
infallibly good
right yes your emotions can lead you
astray but like try living without them
and see how rational you can be right
your agency will be crippled
and I mean that seriously
that would be my 50. the six has to do
with it it's a somewhat technical term
exceptation which is drawn from
evolutionary theory let me give you a
a clear example
so I'm using my tongue to speak right
but tongues did not evolve for speech if
they did all the animals with tongues
would be talking to us right what you
have is you have a very flexible muscle
right because it's for mastication and
it has a lot of very fine nerve endings
because it's for poison and sucrose
detection and things like that and it
happens to be in the air passageway so
you've got something that's like
pre-adapted already almost perfectly
built for being a speaking machine and
so acceptation is you take something and
you repurpose it and this is the work of
Michael Anderson like the way the
cerebellum has been repurposed from
being a like a sensory motor balance
thing to being how we balance and move
around in abstract space right
and so
that acceptation
the idea of Michael Anderson more recent
work especially in Dahan and others is
the brain is constantly doing that the
brain is constantly exacting
things like machines that have been
built for doing one thing and then they
get repurposed or they also use the
language of circuit reuse like from
computer science right that has been
repurposed
huh I like the 60s
do you have any
hmm I'm being very careful with my
language here so I'll try not to be
because it'll end up being too clunky if
I self-edit too intensely
do you have any heretical beliefs
about
Consciousness that
people in the space would strongly
disagree with or think are unfounded yet
you have some degree of conviction in
yes all right if people are interested
in this I have a more long form
presentation of of a talk I gave at the
in Thunder Bay at the conference on
Consciousness and conscience I talk
about the three questions of
consciousness
and so the first question is the
question everybody's really fixated on
which is the nature question which is
how is something that seems so
non-physical how does it possibly exist
in
the otherwise physical universe and
that's the nature question and of course
you have chalmer's version of the hard
problem and qualia and things like that
I'll come back to qualia in a second
now there's another question which is as
equally important and P and people don't
give it enough
attention and they should and this is
the function question which is what is
consciousness for what does it do
and before you give me an answer let me
try and make this more problematic to
you you do a lot of very very
sophisticated stuff without
Consciousness you are taking the noises
coming out of my face hole and
translating them into ideas in your mind
and you have no idea how that process
works you have no introspective access
to it right right
I make noises you have ideas what's
happening in between don't know right
yeah or think about the complex
sophisticated action you can do how
little attention you have to bring to
walking or even and you've had this I no
doubt probably Highway hypnotism where
you've been driving and and you realize
for the past 15 I haven't been paying
attention to the road at all and yet
this sort of philosophy this sort of
zombie inside me has been managing me to
keep me on the road and this right and I
wouldn't rely on it or anything but you
did right so
the question is we seem to be able to
our unconscious seems to be so powerful
what why do we have Consciousness what's
it do and why do we love it so much yeah
right
and then the third question is the meta
question what's the relationship between
these questions so here's my first
heresy
unlike many people I think these two
questions have to be answered in a
completely integrated fashion I think
trying to answer the nature question
without answering the function question
is doomed to fail and I think trying to
answer the function question without
trying to answer the nature question is
doomed to fail so there's the first
vervecan heresy and I don't know who
who's going to be devil's advocate for
me but anyways I know that'd be the
opposite of that to be the person
putting me on trial
so that's the first here's the second
the second is
we can do this
we can find
a way of answering this
if we pay attention to a convergence
that is occurring about what is the
function of consciousness
and then I think this gives us a lot of
the machinery for explaining a lot of
the qualia
that are so Central to the nature of
consciousness qualia
being qualia means the subjective feel
the redness of red to you it's not just
you're not just unconsciously reacting
to wavelengths you're having this
experience of redness that's a qualia
and that seems to be something in
Consciousness and it's subjective in
nature and we don't even know if you're
calling my qualia are the same right
very often they're not right
I mean Japan is a good example of that
right I mean they're like green and blue
are not the same green and blue that we
see depending on you know the the the
crosswalk go signals and so on and even
a person who's colorblind right has
different quality or is Thomas Nagel
famously argued bats who use
echolocation have qualia that we don't
have yeah right right okay so that's
what that means and that's the hard
problem because there doesn't seem to be
any way of explaining
their nature but I think if you get into
and this is work I'm doing with a whole
bunch of other people so I don't want to
take sole credit but I think if you make
use of functionality and you make use of
the four kinds of knowing and things
like this I think you can give an
integrated answer there is a consensus
emerging and I've published on this and
talked about this around what
Consciousness does what's it for and
then I think once you get that and you
open up that functionality you actually
get a phenomenology you get an you get
an explanation of the experience out of
that so the converging thing is that
what Consciousness is for and it
overlaps with attention and working
memory and fluid intelligence
think about when you're driving on the
highway when do you come back to it if
there's something unexpected happens or
there's a really complex situation
suddenly emerging or there's an
ill-defined problem that you're not
quite sure how to formulate and frame
that's what you need Consciousness for
so what is consciousness it's this
higher order relevance realization it's
about
re-realizing what's relevant and
important so that you can deal with the
added challenge of zeroing in on
relevant information that is given to
you by novelty complexity and
ill-definedness that's what
Consciousness for it's this it's
enhanced relevance realization that's
why it overlaps with working memory and
things like that now that does sound
like a Consciousness that would extend
to animals other than
humans totally it helps to explain our
intuition about this generally when
people are willing to extend the
attribution of Consciousness they
actually do it in a way without
realizing that tracks how much fluid
intelligence
do they think that organism has because
fluid intelligence working memory
attention all of these things are about
relevance realization and enhancing it
and so you've got this consensus okay
now let's say we get relevance
realization
and that consciousness of higher order
version what about qualia
well first of all let's divide qualia
and this is this is the second verveiki
heresy let's divide qualia into two
kinds of qualia
there's the typical quality that
philosophers love to talk about the
adjectival qualia like blueness and
greenness and sweetness but there are
adverbial qualia there are qualias of
hereness nowness togetherness of my
experience I'm here I'm now my
experience is together there's a unity
and a here now presence uh presencing of
Consciousness the adverbial
now here's the thing
here's the thing
talk to people who have engaged in
long-term meditative practice and this
is well documented read Foreman for the
documentation I've I've been here in
this state and you get into a state
called the pure Consciousness event
you're not conscious of anything you're
definitely not conscious of inequality
you're not conscious of any thought
you're not even conscious of
Consciousness you're just conscious
you don't black out you're just
conscious you all you have is a pure
perspectival participatory knowing of
con you're conscious by being conscious
and there's nothing else going on
what's interesting about that is you
don't black out because you can remember
being there in that state there's no
adjectival qualia but Consciousness is
still present
so think about that for a second but
what doesn't go away you don't live you
don't lose the hereness because people
say in the pure Consciousness event I
was fully there's full presence
right you don't lose nowness they talk
about I mean eternity this pure nowness
and they don't talk they don't lose
togetherness they talk about pure
Oneness and unity
the adverbial qualia are on steroids and
the adjectival qualia have gone away
yeah that's interesting it's a good way
to put it the adjectival qualia are not
necessary and there's other arguments
they're not sufficient for Consciousness
Consciousness is primarily about
adverbial qualia and a verbal qualia can
be explained by relevance realization
it's how are things relevant to you that
gives you Ascent the centeredness to
consciousness
how the timing of things is an important
part of relevance how things belong
together fit together that's relevance
realization gives you the adverbial
qualia so if you understand the
functionality of Consciousness as
heightening
relevance realization it will be present
in all of those adverbial qualia and
there will be a sense of those even
being heightened when you're in a pure
Consciousness State that's the third and
last for vacation heresy so it's a
completely naturalistic explanation of
consciousness
okay I've got a number of follow-up
questions here I need to set the table a
little bit so I was overseas and ended
up in conversation with two
very smart Russian emigres who had
a lot of a lot of biophysics yeah
background and exposure and we're having
a lot of coffee or I was having a lot of
coffee
at least one of them were only drinking
tea nonetheless ended up talking about
and by talking I mean me listening to
them talk about Quantum effects in the
brain and I I it was well above my pay
grade but it led me to really want to
have someone on the podcast at some
point who can who can credibly speak
because there are a lot of wackadoodles
and all sorts of new age stuff who would
love to try to talk about this but
someone who has credible scientific Bona
fides that would allow them to talk
about this and this leads to my question
which hopefully doesn't
get me too many hackles from the
audience it probably will get a few
do you have any any thoughts on pan
psychism is it just nonsense in in your
view is there plausibly something to it
they're very seem to be very strong
feelings on on many sides related to
this do you have any any thoughts or
opinions on the matter
yeah so I mean the quantum thing I mean
the the best people the I think would be
Penrose and hammeroff people like that
yep I think I think you face I mean I
think it's undeniable we have empirical
evidence that there's Quantum stuff
going on in smell I think that's
undeniable is there Quantum stuff going
on in the kind of Consciousness that is
overlapping with attention and working
memory and intelligence no because you
show all kinds of limitations that are
clear evidence that you are operating
like a classical machine like all the
biases I talked about and all the ways
you ignore all kinds of information blah
blah blah blah and you also have weird
you have problems about temperature and
you have problems so I think those
people give the best representation I'm
giving you why I'm not convinced by that
I think there's a the evidence against
it is significantly greater than any
evidence for it and like you I don't
like the argument that goes
Consciousness is weird Quantum is weird
therefore Clock Fitness is quantum like
that that's just really right now parent
psychism is a different thing and you
don't have to be convinced about Quantum
stuff to be you know a pen psychist
totally right and so do you mind I
should have defined my terms would you
mind just giving people an overview of
what pan psychism is
pan psychism is a version of what's
called well I would argue it's a version
of what's called Elemental property
dualism yep and so the idea here is
we have we have fundamental building
blocks of our ontology
space Time Force matter energy and we
may move those around but right that
that's not important right now and and
we don't try and explain them we've used
them to explain other things because
they're fundamental
and like I say we might physics some
people are arguing we may reject time
and space is fundamental and move to
something deeper I don't know but that's
not relevant to the the core of the
argument the core of argument is that
Consciousness is like that Consciousness
is a fundamental ontological building
block and therefore the attempt to
explain it with any of the other
fundamental building blocks is
impossible you can't do it because they
are at the same ontological ontology
meaning the structure of reality they
are at the same ontological level
there's the basement level in terms of
which you explain everything else so you
can't
the attempt to try and explain them is a
misframing of the kind of thing they are
and so that means if
Consciousness is such a fundamental
ontological building block like you know
space time energy force right and energy
and matter are convertible and Einstein
right you find them there is no part of
reality where they even empty space
right has got all of these fundamental
ontological building blocks
and if Consciousness is such a
fundamental building block it is also
showing up in all in everything so my
table has Consciousness oh not my
full-blown Consciousness but it has what
it's like to be a table
like my Consciousness is about
perspectival knowing right and so it has
what's it's like to be a table it has an
inner subjective experiential aspect now
not full-blown like mine nobody's
ridiculous in claiming there's some sort
of Consciousness like mind somehow
trapped in this table unable to speak or
something like that because we have no
evidence for that but the idea is that
there are aspects of what it is to be a
table that are what it's like to be a
table for the table and not for me or
for you and that would be what the claim
of pan psychism is the best the person
who best makes it plausible to my mind
well not necessarily agreeing is a
colleague of mine
Phil Seeger he's made a very strong case
for the plausibility of pan psychism now
I reject pan psychism although I I
accept things that come close to it in
some important ways
what do you reject and what do you
accept
I don't think that there's anything like
perspectival knowing going on at the
level of the table but
I'm not
I I'm confident enough about my
ignorance of Consciousness and reality
to not say I'm I'm sure and slam on this
table
I do think and this is work of Evan
Thompson and others in foreign I think
they're in like 11. I think there's a
deep continuity I think meaning the
principles of Consciousness have a deep
continuity with the principles of
cognition which have a deep continuity
with the principles of Life which have a
deep continuity with the principles of
self-organization which have a deep
continuity with some of the fundamental
ways in which reality unfolds for us and
so they're not identical you can't
simply reduce the upper level to the
lower levels but there are shared
principles all the way through
and I think the evidence for a deep
continuity hypothesis is very good and
the arguments are very important
so I do think
I do think for example it's proper to
say that there is a rudimentary
cognition for a paramecium it's a
cognitive agent
it's detecting the sugar molecule as
food and this other molecule as poison
it's it's it's a little bit of an aspect
a little bit of a perspective and it
allows it to care about this rather than
that now is that what you and I have no
something like that does that extend
below living things I don't think so
because self-organizing things like the
fire don't seem to direct their behavior
to preserve their own existence the way
living things do and I think that's a
fundamental difference in how things are
organized and how they function so I
don't think Consciousness and cognition
or agency drop below the level of living
things
this is not directly related but I'm
curious you're mentioning the intimacy
the
let's call it atypical intimacy that
nonetheless seems um paraphrasing
familiar to yeah those who are doing
circling
and I'm wondering what are some of the
most unusual
modes of cognition or relating or
perceiving that you have noticed in
those types of exercises yeah and
circling and philosophical fellowship
and exactly video logos all of these
first of all especially when you take
three people through this and they start
doing a lot of that whole ecology and
dialectical logos they will discover a
nestings of intimacies they will
discover first interpersonal intimacy
between you and I yep and then they'll
discover intimacy between all of us and
what is called the we space this
emergent sort of dynamical system
that is sort of linking us and coupling
us all together people to start to get a
sense of intimacy to the we space or
Chris and I call it the logos or a
German word the Geist right
and then there's a third intimacy that
people sometimes get to which is they
start to get an intimacy through the
interpersonal and through the intimacy
with the we space to sort of like the
ground the the origin the fount of
intelligibility they get a sense of
intimacy that we talked about earlier as
a sense of the Sacred and what's really
interesting about this is
people from all kinds of backgrounds
resolutely secular will start to use
spiritual and religious language to talk
about these kinds of intimacies
yeah that's that's some curious I I
think indicator right it's like when
yeah when secular language fails where
do you go uh oh yeah what are you gonna
do
you as as I understand it had an office
I believe directly across the hall or or
close to
Dr Jordan Peterson and my question is
where with respect to the
finding or creation of meaning or
meaning broadly speaking
where would you say you most strongly
the two of you most strongly agree and
where do you most strongly disagree
way before Jordan became a god Jordan I
we used to regularly show up at
conferences we shared students
a lot we we had some public debates I
mean in the proper good sense
and so Jordan shares with me this this
idea of relevance realization as a as a
core problem to be explained and
understood
and that that the relevance realization
gives us that sense of religio that
sense of connectedness because we're
it's how we're coupled
non-propositionally to the world the
unit we've already talked about this
Jordan and I share that a lot and he's
very very interested and often
supportive of the work I do on relevance
realization intelligence consciousness
meaning and the cultivation of wisdom
and so that's where we have some very
significant agreements
he places more emphasis on the narrative
on narrative than I do I think
non-narrative I think narrative is very
important I want to make that very clear
I don't I don't think we become
temporarily extended moral agents
without narrative but I think their
narrative depends on pre-narrative
dialogical capacities and we can move
post narrative because this is what many
people in wisdom Traditions mystical
Traditions report they move
post-narrative and you see techniques
for getting people to go post narrative
like think about the Zen Cohen it's
designed to get you into a narrative and
then break narrative apart or Jesus of
nazareth's Parables that's they sound
like stories and there's a narrative and
you read the prodigal son and then who
am I supposed to identify with who's
right like is it this is it the father
is it the prodigal son is it the El and
you realize if you settle on any one of
those you haven't got it and it blows
The Narrative apart you know and Jesus
so it doesn't sound as pretentious I
mean it respectfully Jesus is a master
of saying these things that sort of blow
people apart
right Blow The Narrative apart so I I
think he and we have done this publicly
he and I had a discussion with Jonathan
pajo and you know I and I was
challenging Jonathan and
Jordan about the emphasis on the
narrative and that of course comes from
Jordan from his
his jungian background and from Jonathan
from his Eastern Orthodox although
Jonathan to give him
do credit came around later and he
released a video where he said John's
right the normal logical is not
reducible to the narrative there's ways
in which we connect to reality that are
non-narrative and are important and I
thought that was really good of him so
that'd be one area where Jordan and I
disagree do you have to get the
narrative before you can go post
narrative I think so I think so and and
this is where I think the difference is
I think that narrative is indispensable
but I do not think that means it's
metaphysically necessary let me give you
an analogy my only language that I'm
fluent in is English English is
indispensable to be being a cognitive
agent and communicating but I wouldn't
claim it is metaphysically necessary
that every cognitive agent speak in
English and only in English or or has to
know English you know that's ridiculous
see so you have to make a distinction
between indispensability and I think
narrative is developmentally
indispensable but I don't think it's
metaphysically necessary to our to the
full development of our cognition okay
so you have that disagreement you have
different weighting of narrative and
the ultra not the alternative but the
term that you mentioned your your
colleague used the nomological having to
do like structures the Lilac structures
were really there we go laws and
theories are powerful and important in a
way that's not reducible to narratives
right that's one area and then another
area is I put a lot more emphasis on
practices and theorizing and helping to
engineer practices and Ecology of
practices than Jordan does that's
another major why do you think that is
what would his
response to that be would you imagine
part of it I think In fairness to him is
background and part of it has to do I
think with
Jordan is a very complex person I
respect Jordan I consider him a
colleague and I consider him a friend
and what I want to say very clearly and
and I do this to his face by the way and
because I do it respectfully and
dialogically Jordan is fine with this we
disagree about things for example I
think post-modernism and Foucault
there's a lot to be learned there I have
criticisms of them but there are
important arguments that need to be
engaged with I have argued this with
Jordan to his face he disagrees he
thinks that post-modernism is largely
crypto Marxism
etc etc and he rejects it sort of to
core I'm not I'm not denying that
that post-modernism has been taken by
people in this way but I would also say
that many people invoke derida and
Foucault and they've not actually read
darada and Foucault Darren I was very
interested in
neoplatonism and Foucault was very
interested tour in Hado and stoicism
towards the end of his career and
there's reasons for that I think you
have to have a much more nuanced
understanding of post-modernism now I've
made that argument to Jordan any and we
disagree about it but because I respect
him and we enter into genuine dialogue
that's fine right now the the problem is
Jordan also has this other side where
and he doesn't do this with me
where he gets he's very confrontational
and he admits this and he gets very
polemical
and it's usually in the political domain
and that's that's an area when he and I
don't agree very much
but
to his credit right you know
Jordan respects that he and I can have
significant different political
commitments and nevertheless get into
deep and important discussions of
philosophical and scientific Merit
I have to say that because I'm really
tired of people saying that because I
talked to Jordan and because I maintain
the relationship that pre-existed his
godhood
that I am somehow
you know
advising or advocating for all of
everything he says that's ridiculous I
directly criticize him about a lot of
things it's just I think it should be
done in the way that we do it and we've
always done it and so
that's a hard thing my relationship to
him is a challenge for me I've
considered both options I've considered
sort of just sort of throwing in and I'm
part of the petersonian camp and it's
like no I can't do that I can't do that
in all honesty I disagree with Jordan
about politics as the main area I
disagree for philosophical reasons with
Jordan about politics being the main
area in which we can solve the meaning
crisis politics is at the propositional
level and is at the adversarial level we
need we need the non-propositional
that's the main place where the meaning
crisis is going to be addressed I would
argue I disagree with him about that
I've disagreed with him about particular
philosophical stances like his stance on
post-modernism
Etc
and so completely identifying him would
be inauthentic completely rejecting him
would be inauthentic we share a lot of
concerns we I admire many of his ideas I
think he's made he's done good work
published work he continues to make good
argument he's an insightful person and I
have an ongoing history with him and he
he talks to people that I talk to like
so I'm in this I'm damned if I do damned
if I don't so I I sort of just say well
okay what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to show up and interact with him
as philosophically and scientifically
honestly as I can
yeah I had Jordan on on this podcast and
it was incredible to see how strongly
binary not just the reasons
but also the expectations of me were are
you all in or are you all out and
there was part of me that wanted to say
this is this is the kind of identity
politics
morass that we have is such an issue
to have any kind of reconciliation and
civil debate it can't be well I'm making
a strong statement but like it shouldn't
be shouldn't have to be that black or
white I think there are many I want to
strengthen your argument for you I want
to strengthen you please I need someone
to do this with me more regularly this
has to do with adaptivity this has to do
with intelligence let's just give you an
example of relevance realization right
now right here right now you have two
attentional systems probably more but at
least these two right you have the task
Focus that is trying to keep you focused
on what what it what is John saying with
his multi-syllabic complex sentences and
then there's a part of you the default
mode Network that's mind wandering and
I'm not accusing you of anything it's
drifting away it's thinking about other
things and they're they're locked
together like Evolution the Mind
wandering introduces variation you the
tax Network kills most of it off but
some of it survives and helps reproduce
the conversation and keep it going
opponent processing your autonomic
nervous system about arousal sympathetic
is bias to arousing you parasympathetic
is biased to getting you to calm down
and they're locked together in opponent
processing you find this all through
adaptive systems opponent processing
democracy I argued this when I gave a
talk at the in the International
Symposium on democracy and Prague in
September right democracy should be
opponent processing the best way for me
to correct my perspectival bias is to
have you be an opponent processing with
me you take a different bias but we
agree that we are each other's best
means of self-correction that's how
democracy should work and we have
degenerated it into adversarial the
other side is evil and must be destroyed
because we are perfectly right and
correct with it sinful and I use that
word advisedly a sinful
self-righteousness on both sides a pox
on both of your houses I would say to
that because you're undermining the very
opponent processing
that is necessary for democracy to be a
good means for us to use extended
cognition to solve our complex problems
so that time strengthening your argument
that's what I meant to say so thank you
much I think much much it goes to
something I said earlier stop trying to
demonize or deify any one of your
faculties stop trying to demonize or
deify Jordan confront his argument
argument by argument some of them are
good some of them are bad even his some
of his bad arguments need to be taken
seriously because they're well made and
they contain Insight some of the things
you reject but reject it because of the
content of the argument not because of
the side you're on what is that
accomplishing right that is not
accomplishing any overcoming of your or
my self-deception all it's doing is
reinforcing whatever confirmation bias
we are already enslaved to talking about
opponent processing makes me think about
some of my close friendships and
how I choose to develop friendships with
people who can help with the checks and
balances and yes
the constructive pushback
when helpful and that leads me to want
to ask you and this is very
self-interested of me but it's something
that's on my mind a lot because most of
my friends are non-religious but looking
to create meaning or Find meaning as we
all are how would you advise say a group
of middle-aged friends
to support one another in having more
meaningful lives or creating meaning
what can people do
in a in a small cohort
would you have any recommendations
don't just swap beliefs right
it's insufficient it's just a
propositional
commit to taking up together
a living Ecology of practices
commit to doing that together
and bring that opponent processing into
the non-propositional aspects of your
cognition into the extended aspects of
your cognition learn how to do some of
these practices I've been talking about
take them up together and take up ones
that involve you practicing together
because I mean a big part of what the
church and the temple and the mosque did
was exactly that they provided a home
a tradition
in which ecologies of practices were
properly homed and supported so that
people could come together and not just
communicate but commune together by
sharing participation I'm emphasizing
all these words because of all the ways
we've talked about them right in shared
ecologies of practices that they
mutually conform to and transform
themselves to and thereby mutually set
up a space
where they can afford each other's
transformations
the way you can cultivate together
enhanced religio enhanced sense of
sacredness enhanced sense of the depths
within you calling to the depths of
others and the calling to the depths of
reality
don't tell me what you believe tell me
what you practice tell me how you're
practicing together and how you're
acting as checks and balances in
opponent processing on the curation the
the creation and the running of these
ecologies of practices that's and commit
to it the way you commit to a friendship
right your friend is a complex dynamical
system an Ecology of practice is a
complex dynamical system it takes time
and effort and commitment and a
willingness to transform and fail and
learn from mistakes in order to make
this work get into an Ecology of
practice
try to get make sure that that Ecology
of practice is in ongoing dialogue and
discussion with the best cognitive
science out there right now so you don't
go off in weird rabbit holes that can
happen when people do this so that you
stay tied to the best science we have
about how cognition and Consciousness
and intelligence and distributed
cognition and flow Etc work that right
that is the single most important thing
now there's lots I've offered Lots I
have a full meditation course and
contemplation course cultivation of
wisdom course I have the whole after
Socrates there's lots out there and you
don't have to just pay attention to me
you can pay attention to the the
ecologies of practices like Rafe Kelly
take a look at the I went to return the
source last summer blew me apart right
just an amazing Ecology of practices
I've been doing a lot of participant
observation and experiment in other
people's ecologies and practices like
you have you have to become a
connoisseur and a creator of ecologies
of practices there's no other way to
enhance the capacity for participating
in meaning that would be the most
Central advice I would give somebody
I was meaning and I will now ask about
after Socrates so you have this this
very popular YouTube series Awakening
from the meeting crisis why create after
Socrates
I listened to the criticism of other
people Awakening from the meeting crisis
has a couple of main criticisms that
people made one was a lot of people
asked at the end yeah but what do I do
now
what do I do now you've convinced me
about the meaning crisis in this problem
and blah blah but what do I do now and
then secondly this is you did this
totally individualistically but how does
this work with other people
so after Socrates is not extensive it's
intensive it's trying to trace the
entire tradition from Socrates right you
know spending a lot of time there about
all of these kinds of reverse engineer
I'm not claiming this is exactly what
Socrates did who could claim that I'm
trying to reverse engineer as best I can
this dialectic into Dia logos this these
kinds of practices we've been talking
about
so that like people can undertake a
pedagogical program
so Tim every every episode is I give an
argument and they build on each other
like Awakening for the meaning crisis
but I also give points of reflection
that are designed to be taken up in
discussion by groups and then I give
instruction in a particular practice
that resonates with the content of the
lecture so as the lecture builds the
argument Intergroup discussion is being
built and a pedagogical program is being
built so that you can come to take up
the socratic way of life in community
with other people who are taking it up
and cultivating and extended and
developed Ecology of practices that's
what after Socrates is all about where
can people find after Socrates where's
the best place for people to go if they
want to learn just go on my YouTube
channel it's right there for free
all right well we will certainly link to
the YouTube channel
the website
johnvervicky.com on Twitter for vaky
underscore John John this has been such
a pleasure I've really enjoyed this
conversation thank you for taking so
much time and being so patient with my
questions hopefully it wasn't too
torturous I do appreciate it at all I
really enjoyed it so much so that I'll
answer your question if you want me ever
to come back I'd be very happy to do so
I would love to do a round two is there
anything else you would like to
say any closing comments any requests
you'd like to make of my audience
anything at all that you'd like to add
before we wind to a close
I don't think so I would ask people
to you know to consider the two series
Awakening from a mini crisis after
Socrates take a look at some of the
conversations I'm having with other
people
try to give me the benefit of the doubt
when I'm talking to people you might not
like
good advice
and so I guess that's that's all I would
have to say right now and and again
I
I was a little intimidated and I'm not
usually thinking about talking to you
you have quite a powerful and like I
said before we turned the recording on a
reputation and
yet you were so welcoming and
accommodating and you you you and I I
think got into the Flow State a mutual
Flow State quite a few times I think it
was
it was really wonderful so thank you
very much oh thank you John thank you
for being such a
great jazz player on the stage and I
really really enjoyed it I took tons of
notes so I have I have quite a lot of of
reading and investigating and
practicing ahead of me yeah and to
everybody listening as per usual we all
have links to everything I may need to
do some work on my spelling of various
names but we'll figure it out in the
show notes at tim.blog slash podcast and
until next time please be just a bit
Kinder than is necessary that includes
to yourself but certainly to other
people and remember it's not just what
you believe it is what you practice so
get to practicing folks and as always
thanks for tuning in
thank you everyone and I thought we
would start with a Sandbox that that I
like to play in and I think you are a
black belt where I am still a middling
white belt and that's a discussion of
language and words and specifically I
was hoping you could perhaps give us
some examples of words that we use
commonly
that frame the way we think about life
or relate to life
in the west if that is perhaps a
container that works for the question
yeah I think it's a good container I so
I think there are words that like are
signpost benchmarks for a kind of
cultural cognitive grammar
giving us some sort of our basic
conceptual vocabulary
so too that come to mind very readily
are these two terms subjective and
objective and people of course forget
the original meanings of these words but
what we do is we have taken them to be
an exhaustive division of reality
there's the interior subjective mind
stuff and there's the exterior objective
physical stuff and we take it that
that's just the way it is and that's how
we've always thought and that's how
everybody has always thought about
reality and that's not true
the Greeks didn't have that Division and
of course many Eastern philosophies
don't have that division
and there's been critiques of that
framework which we got from Descartes
the Cartesian framework for about the
last 200 years even in the history of
Western philosophy so the fact that we
have these terms we Bandy them about we
think that that's all there is it's
complete and exhaustive and they're
divided and they're really radically
incommensible with each other
it just shows how well how well this has
insinuated itself into the very way we
see ourselves see the World Experience
ourselves
and it's very powerful and very
interesting and part of my work is to
try to undermine that dichotomy and try
and get us to think
more profoundly about that there must be
something deeper than the subjective and
objective that fundamentally makes it
possible for them to be related together
because if not we are really doomed in a
kind of radical skepticism and solipsism
solipsism is the idea that you the only
thing that's really real is your own
mind kind of thing
so that would be one clear example
another one along those lines that we we
haven't paid attention to how much it's
changed is the word matter we now take
matter as actual stuff but if you go
before the Scientific Revolution matter
in the Aristotelian framework means
exactly the opposite it means pure
potentiality that which is awaiting to
be informed
and actualized so Aristotle's notion is
like a piece of wood is potentially a
chair or a table and what makes it act
actuality what makes it act like a table
is its form its structure and functional
organization what makes it act like a
chair is its form but before that it's
just a potential
chair or a potential table and that's
what matter was it was sort of this pure
potential and so the word has actually
flipped in meaning radically and then we
of course think that it's always been
this way and we forget that there's a
dramatically opposite possibility even
within our own history so that would be
too easy
well not easy to reflect upon but easy
to to bring up examples of words that
are very powerful in our culture so much
so that we we see so much by means of
them that they're almost completely
transparent to us
how has your relating to and I apologize
if the wording on this is Clumsy but
you're relating to your experienced
reality changed as you've studied
cognitive science and philosophy and
these different labels and Frameworks
that despite our
perhaps underlying subconscious belief
that it has always been this way in in
the case of say subjective objective
how has your own relating to Life's
experience changed icoin to termed the
transjective to mean that which binds
the the two together
that which binds the inner life of the
organism to the outer world of the
environment kind of thing and there I
was influenced by a teacher of mind
John Kennedy who was a protege of JJ
Gibson let me give you an example I've
become aware of things so Gibson had a
notion of an affordance like so this
water bottle is graspable now the
graspability isn't in my hand I can't
grasp anything I can't grasp Africa or
something like that right and the grass
Mobility isn't in the bottle because
like an ant can't grasp it and Etc right
and it's it's actually a real relation
of fittedness between my hand and this
and the floor is walkable by me right
and so this way of of experiencing this
connectedness as a more profound way of
experiencing my mental life has now
become increasingly prominent in Salient
for me it goes towards the main work I
do on
scientific work about relevance
realization and things like that but it
also overlaps
you know I do Taoist practices I do tai
chi Chuan and Qigong and things and and
that sense of connectedness that is
talked about
that shift helps me get into that sense
of connectedness in a more profound and
transformative way so it's made it
nobody's ever asked me that question
that's a really good question it has
really changed
sort of the configurations of my
experience what is foregrounded what
becomes Salient to me what such that it
I can actually taste it more in my
experience and be transformed more by it
yes very much so that's a very clear
example and that sorry I'll stop in a
sec but this is long form you can go as
long as you like well that translates in
really I mean how do I say this without
sounding like a Hallmark card but like
you move to an understanding of love as
this connectedness but not as the idea
of connectedness but is the real
reciprocal opening between you and
another person they disclose to you in a
way that allows you to disclose to them
and you're mutually affording that and
that goes from being something that you
just think to something that you found
yourself deeply being shaped by as you
participate in it
I'm glad I asked and I I hope to ask why
I'm going to ask many more we've got
plenty of time this is fun so I I wanted
to come back to something you mentioned
and that is I'm going to paraphrase here
because
I can't recall the exact wording that
you used but effectively some interwoven
fabric that is more fundamental than the
subjective objective sure dichotomy that
we use
and and I'm curious if that is
an older way of knowing if that is a so
it's a revisiting of an older way of
knowing or relating to reality
or if that is
a newer
sort of way of thinking about something
that could connect and underlie yeah
those types of Concepts and and I'm
asking in part because I had a
conversation a few weeks ago with Wade
Davis who's an ethnographer and yeah
I've read one of his books yeah yeah and
he's written quite a bit about different
ways
of knowing which I I certainly want to
dive into with you as well so is is what
you refer to something old is it
something new is it something that has
no temporal fixed point
well the answer is both
and that's not as that's not a Copo
Canadian answer and what I mean by that
is there's definitely important
provenance and I'll talk about it in a
sec but I'm not recommending that we
simply think we can return to that in
some sort of a historical manner so if
that's what I mean when I'm sort of
caveating this notion that our
relationship to reality
is more about this connectedness that
this is obviously in the platonic and
the whole neoplatonic tradition
this idea of
participation that
so you know
one way the Ancients thought about it is
well this has a structural functional
organization to it that allows it to act
the way it does and who who best knows
this somebody who could describe it and
for people who have audio only this
you're pointing at the water bottle oh
sorry yeah sorry yeah
so right so yeah thanks for that now who
actually knows this better somebody who
could describe it or somebody could make
it well you generally people say well
somebody who could actually make it who
could actually bring about the
structural functional organization so
what does the maker have in their head
well they have the structural functional
organization and they just have to put
it into that so the thing that makes
this act the way it does is it is
identical to Something in Your Mind
and you're both sharing in that so this
is called a contact epistemology right
you're actually in car that you're
mutually participating and so the
relatedness and the connectedness is
more primordial that and that's sort of
an idea running through the whole
neoplatonic tradition which I would
argue following Arthur versus Lewis is
really the spiritual grammar of the West
is the neoplatonic tradition so in that
sense it's old
in another sense it's very new because
what's coming out of four e cognitive
science
is exactly this kind of thing and this
has to do with ways of knowing and I I
talk about because of the work I do in
foreign four kinds of knowing and when
we can get into that but the point is
that three of those four kinds of
knowing are about this kind of
connectedness and mutual participation
and so
and I find this very interesting the the
sort of Cutting Edge cogs eye is arguing
that this is a better way of like even
to use the metaphor your mind is not in
your head it's between your embodied
brain and the world that's where the
mind is and that's how you should think
of the mind and and that and that's
really cutting edge and you know and
important and there's a lot of important
work being done about it but in a lot of
ways it Harkens back to that ancient
neoplatonic tradition so it's both old
and new and really really persuasive
ways I would say